[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et salut à tous bonjour tout le monde et
bienvenue pour cette 13e partie Fab 13e
partie du match de championnat du monde
partie de tous les dangers pour pour les
deux d'ailleurs on se rapproche du terme
de ce match très serré 6 points partout
on a vu hier une partie nombreuses
erreurs mais dont Ding est sorti
victorieux et donc on se demande dans
quel état les joueurs vont être
aujourd'hui si un époque aura récupéré
il sera en état de jouer
si il faudra sécher la partie et se dire
allez je prends le jour de repos après
je me suis content j'essaie de faire nul
les noirs et je voulais des partages
bref
c'est la question qu'on va on en
discuter ce matin au petit déj en
discute souvent en échec au petit déj
avant avant les commentaires et alors là
aujourd'hui c'est le premier jour on ne
sait absolument pas ce qui va se passer
bon en fait on sait jamais non mais je
sais mais d'habitude on a enfin on a une
idée et puis des fois on a raison des
fois on a tort enfin ça ça dépend
regarde tu avais senti le système de
Londres mais c'est calme mais c'est pas
loin c'est un peu le c'est un peu le
même esprit
faut pas dire oui je me sens t'inquiète
et puis il perd vraiment un coup quoi
donc
voilà on va avoir on va voir
ce que je choisis digne déjà est-ce que
berlinoise enfin non ça attend un anti
Marshall mais
mais en fait on sait pas trop ce qu'on
sait pas trop comment les joueurs vont
aborder la partie après l'ouverture
c'est même pas forcément on a eu plein
de dinguerie toute façon dans dans le
match donc voilà quoi on a scénario
favori alors attends c'est le mauvais
nombre de parties ouais exactement enfin
heureusement que tu le pointes et ça
c'est grave parce qu'on pourrait penser
que c'est la deuxième partie du match et
heureusement qu'on a du Fab qui vient
nous ouais nous signaler que c'est la
partie numéro 13 ça c'est extrêmement
important Fab
et évidemment c'est corrigé tu te sens
mieux là tu respires non
les commentaires vont pouvoir être en
adéquation avec la partie du jour
il refait des trois
il repart sur ce qu'il a joué
ronde 11 où il y avait B5 full B3
D6 à 3 cavaliers à 5 x 2 la même partie
enfin c'est la même nul D6
et là il y avait il repart c'est ça
au début du match
moi j'aurais tenté le match du berger à
sa place
ça peut
H3 et ça va repartir avec lui
parce que tu veux moi
il est déjà parti Yann
il peut faire partir comme ça c'est pas
c'est trop vite c'est pas bon signe je
crois je me barre mais c'est il
recommence un peu le cinéma qui nous
avait offert pendant son match contre
contre manus alors il a jamais vraiment
quitté à 100% mais là il quitte quand
même pour moi
il quitte quand même la table un petit
peu tôt Fab ça ça
dénote un stress quand même très très
élevé côté il y a une attention de pas
faire bises répétita et replonger comme
au match précédent attention pour Yann à
mon avis c'est la partie de tous les
dangers
et ils savent il est parti d'un pas
pressant
et c'est par quoi
mais ouais non Yann quand même qui
[Musique]
qui part un peu vite pour moi après une
femme un commentaire là dessus
non je sais pas trop quoi dire
on verra
est-ce que ça dénote pas quand même d'un
stress incontrôlé et incontrôlable ça
peut bien sûr
mais là c'est peut-être plus l'oeil de
l'ancien joueur poker qui peut parler
ouais bah généralement une ancien joueur
de poker c'est pas bon signe
ça c'est pas bon signe
donc le revient mais tu vois il revient
un peu nos Challans un peu partout
elle va être dur cette partie à mon avis
ça peut partir sur des dingues ça peut
être une partie extraordinaire
du coup je connais pas
mais je pense que
on dit que c'était une nouveauté alors
peut-être
c'est sûr
pas de base de données mais faut 3
tu peux ouvrir un truc à côté où ça va
ouvrir un truc à côté
faut pas faire bugger l'ordi c'est quand
même plus important qu'on est le stream
alors attends on va on va tenter de
faire bugger l'ordi on prend un risque
les amis tout peut s'arrêter
ons
tout peut s'arrêter
non pas nouveau mais par contre au
niveau personnage à faire ouais
nouveauté quand même
cet exemple title Tuesday par Jamal
oudim 2045 54 chaise comme contre contre
Nicky à la chimie
1945 chastom crois ça devait être une
game
je vais la regarder je dommage on peut
pas vous la partager ici mais je la
regarde pour le plaisir
ouais franchement ça joue pas mal en
fait ok ça joue peut-être mieux que la
partie qu'on a vu hier en Championnat du
Monde côté
c'est un peu craqué
ouais donc nouveauté alors
c'est logique que je connaisse pas
donc oui bon on aurait plutôt eu
l'habitude de voir tout un et qui a eu
des deux qui allait on en avait déjà
parlé
mais bon on peut vous le redire du coup
au lieu de fou B7 si les Noirs font
cavaliers à 5 vous C2 c'est 5
c'est alors entre chigorine de
l'espagnol avec un temps d'écart mais en
fait on peut jouer des quatre quoi qu'il
arrive avec les Blancs et maintenant
après la théorie moderne des ordis
il a joué 7 x 3 cavaliers à 5 ou C2
c'est 5 il y avait les BD 2 je suis
étonné qui joue si vite
non c'est possible mais je suis étonné
quand même
et quoi qu'il en soit j'aurais quand
même passé plus de temps à sa place
parce que ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que en fait il ne joue que ce plan
tout le temps sur tout ce qui bouge sur
les Espagnols depuis le début du match
donc en fait tu peux dire bon il
s'attend à ce que je fasse ça ok c'est
mes analyses tu les vérifies et tu
regardes s'il y a pas s'il y a pas un
truc je sais pas
là
de toute façon il sait qu'il va le jouer
oh mais tu es pas sûr tu as le droit
aussi de faire vite
parce que tu sais tu le cliques et puis
tu perds pas ton temps il a quand même
perdu une partie du match tu vois même
un point et demi sur le fait qu'il a
trop réfléchi sur rien du tout en
réalité il pourrait déjà être à cette
ennemi indigne bon tu me diras Yann il
aurait dû gagner hier aussi donc
finalement
en fait l'un dans l'autre qui est
égalisé c'est plus ou moins logique
après vu le contenu du match hier il y a
du s'envoler
mais est-ce qu'il aurait dû mener au
score si on le score est logique en
réalité il y en a pas un qui au-dessus
de l'autre
en fait on a dit que le hey game de Ding
était au dessus de celui de népo que le
bégaye de nepo est au-dessus de celui de
Ding mais le Sega game de Ding est
au-dessus de celui de dépôt alors le
problème
l'alphabet trop loin quoi donc il va
quand même jouer quelqu'un connaît
l'alphabet l'alphabet chinois ça marche
comment
je sais pas du tout non mais genre juste
pour voir la tête des des lettres quoi
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui peut nous
mettre ça dans le chat
juste par curiosité
il y a pas d'alphabet non mais bon
j'appelle ça un alphabet parce que j'ai
pas le mot quoi
il y a des congés il y en a des
caractères
mais ils sont bien capables d'écrire des
on phonétiques aussi je crois qu'ils
font et tu peux faire les deux en
chinois non tu peux écrire parfois
éthique aussi
s'appelle les Pignes ok il y en a
combien des pinins on va prendre quelque
chose on va se cultiver ce matin sur
twitch
ouais bon on a pas
et s'il y a une partie de manque c'est
repos non demain c'est repos on souffle
et après ce sera samedi la dernière
partie du match
c'est sympa ça de pouvoir écrire par
idiotram ou par ou par phonétique
d'avoir les deux possibilités je trouve
que c'est chanmé ça en vrai
je trouve que ces champs mais
ça m'a donné envie d'apprendre le
mandarin cette histoire c'est hyper dur
mais oui intéressant
non c'est hyper dur enfin faut vraiment
y passer du temps et c'est intéressant
ah mais pour le coup
après le truc c'est que on est déjà un
peu vieux pour pour être très bon enfin
c'est pas le problème mais
[Musique]
on a moins de plasticité du cerveau et
puis aussi je sais pas combien de langue
tu parles mais bon l'effort d'apprendre
à prendre le Russe
je vais parler pour moi du coup qui
parle que français anglais tu vois je
suis moins bon que des gens qui auraient
déjà appris encore deux trois autres
langues tu te parlera espagnol parler à
autre chose il va s'habitue de portugais
cette mécanique
et donc là de compter sur un alphabet
c'est pas le modèle c'est complètement
différent et une autre structure et tout
ça je moi je sais que j'aurais du mal
mais intellectuellement ça peut être
sympa juste pour
[Musique]
pour le plaisir d'apprendre quelque
chose de nouveau quoi
j'aime bien votre compte je peux
apprendre une nouvelle langue ça me
ferait plaisir parce que quand tu
apprends une nouvelle langue tu en
prends une nouvelle manière de penser
enfin quand tu peux la parler vraiment
bien un pack pas si tu pars à
mais si tu peux réellement la parler
tu ça modifies ta manière de penser
c'est assez intéressant
c'est pas un truc auquel on pense de
base d'autres mots mais en fait ça
réellement et globalement la manière
dont tu penses
dire j'avais un prof à la fac qui se
questionnait
si en fait genre la langue russe était
très adaptée pour bien jouer aux échecs
parce qu'en fait j'ai trouvé spécial toi
qui joue tous bien enfin tout bien
répondre je lui dis bonjour j'en sais
rien moi mec déjà lui il avait compris
que
la langue influencée ta pensée quoi
bah je crois
ce que je parlais couramment je parle
couramment russe
enfin moi pour en faire l'expérience
journal j'atteste de cette théorie c'est
évident ça change même ta perception des
choses genre je veux dire des pays
nordiques je sais pas lesquels mais
peut-être les finlandais je sais plus
ils ont peut-être 14 manières de parler
de la neige
on dit elle est poudreuse ou quoi puis
bon bah c'est pas c'est de la neige
en fait ils ont vu des différences et
ils te les différencie par le fait que
tu puisses les exprimer avec un mot tu
peux les reconnaître après parce que
nous c'est ce qui manquait et
du coup bah nous oui c'est de la neige
c'est de la neige enfin donc
et ça non alors ça pète l'hypothèse de
cette pierres warf ok merci c'est loin
d'être une hypothèse
donc
ce qui connaît ou est-ce qu'il connaît
pas pour le moment les coûts sont
logiques c'est logique pour l'instant on
va voir comment ça évolue
moins logique en fait on va dire c'est
que déjà le la ligne est moins jouée en
fait en général pour tout le monde ici
le grand coup c'est tout droit
mais de loin et des trois c'était jouer
un peu sous un autre esprit de garder le
fou qu'on l'a vu sur la diagonale et la
partie à deux jours avec A3 ou à 4 mais
donc C3 et D3 c'était un peu un truc
inoffensif qui était un une sorte d'anti
Marshall pour fainéant quoi bon que j'ai
fait moi même plus enfin voilà
ou en gros tu dis je joue en Espagne
normal moi je me prends pas la tête avec
le Marshall je connais mes plans et
voilà
et basiquement en fait le fou en C1 il
est quelque part déjà développé dans
l'espagnol sans avoir bougé parce qu'il
contrôle les cases vers le rocade verse
il nous gêne pas la tour 1 on
l'amènerament de l'autre côté tu vois
enfin on n'a pas trop besoin de secours
et
c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir plus de mal
peut-être arriver à faire à faire des
quatre à un moment parce que les normes
vont peut-être mettre plus de pression
dessus et qu'on n'a pas la tour 1 pour
défendre mais si il part du principe que
des quatre il y a peut-être s'en passer
où il le fera dans certains cas de
figure et on verra
pourquoi pas c'est juste être une autre
conception après en soit c'est vrai que
ça a pas l'air stupide de mettre ce
foulard il est là il est là
après pareil alors je sais pas d'un
point de vue plus tactique si les noirs
peuvent commencer à songer à des coups
comme dessin qu'un jour ou l'autre
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire le plan
magnusien fouet F8 G6 fougères 7 pour
des 5 et que tu vois le 3 il peut se
retrouver dans c'est la question que je
voulais te poser
bah ouais enfin après là c'est concret
ça peut et aussi pareil sur des cinq des
calibrant du coup tu touches le fouet 3
donc d'habitude il est tranquille en C1
et que tu fais autre chose et que tu as
l'impression sur le Pione 5 donc il peut
y avoir des défauts mais peut-être qu'il
y a pas de moyens de l'exploiter ou quoi
d'accord en pratique ça va pas être
trouvable facilement et donc voilà
[Musique]
donc on va voir en tout cas on va avoir
une potion un peu différente de ce qu'on
avait d'habitude
puisque
en général dans genre situation n'est
pas partait toujours sur du fuj5
différemment alors peut-être qu'il va
être très fin il va faire feu 3 il faut
G5 mais
on verra
en tout cas Yann qui joue très vite mais
moi j'ai peur pour rien mais je mesure
sur une bonne journée
il va falloir un peu de bol pour Yann
après ça peut enfin j'ai l'impression
que ça me fait penser à des matchs de
tennis où tu as les deux qui tapent là
c'est sans effet
et qui s'envoient des des parpaings mais
il y a pas de il y a plus de contrôle
quoi et c'est bon bah c'est pleine lune
c'est pleine lignes c'est dehors c'est
dehors mais le coup d'après je te
renvoie un parpaing et ça me fait penser
à une finale de Roland-Garros je pense
que c'était
ostapenko Alep on va vieille finale mais
avec Alep donc qui joue normal et on
s'appelle co qui ont eu que des
parpaings alors au début c'est pas passé
du coup à l'appeler et on s'appelle quoi
il gagnait mais enfin c'est l'avait
jamais changé de stratégie c'est vrai
tiens je tape là-bas souvent
mais ça donne cette impression c'est
parpaing sur parpaing quoi puis bon ça
rentre ça rentre ça rentre pas je
dormais quand même
on voit tout le temps que des parpains
ouais c'est absolument rien à
c'est pas mais ça me fait penser à ça
c'est il y a plus de contrôle quoi
game tu fais mal ah bah quand tu as le
Game elle avait défoncé un moment donné
elle était juste un jouable peut-être de
taper tout à 15 10 cm des lignes de dans
le cours
bah autre elle était là elle est là-bas
anti prenait le coup
dans ce coin là c'était
mais ouais donc ça ça fait un peu penser
à ça
mais après ça peut être redoutable enfin
c'est juste que si ça passe tu vas tout
jouer tempo et tu vas mettre l'autre
sous l'eau et tu vas le défoncer et puis
si ça passe pas
ça passe pas
ça fait un peu est-ce que ça te fait
penser à ça aussi où il y a que moi qui
vois ça
bon moi je l'avais pas vu comme ça mais
ne pourraient donc il commence à jouer
tempo
il me fait un peu peur
de déraper
mais en fait si enfin ok il doit se
connaître en fait je sais pas je peux
pas lui donner de leçon mais en fait si
il sent qu'il est dans cet état de style
mais c'est nul quoi
faire pas comme un idiot le match
là-dessus quoi parce que tu es
et si juste là il dans sa prépa et dans
sa prépa ça c'est même pas le problème
mais faut qu'il remonte à partir
de risque
pas quand tu la jouis tu peux la
mélanger parce que hier en fait je pense
que le fou des 7 c'était mélangé enfin
gris il a écrit un truc intéressant bah
on peut en parler rapidement
pour les vendeurs de guéri il y en a
quand même beaucoup
bon j'ai pas mis un mauvais ordre de
coup mais c'est pas important
il a fait ici non c'est trop c'est ça
et du coup c'était dans quelle position
c'était
trois bon dame C7 fouder 3 et là il se
trouve que c'était
pardon pour éviter fou F5 et là il se
trouve que fou des 7 c'est le coup
numéro 1 de l'ordi
parce que faut des trois il veut torcer
8 mais attention la colonne et tu as du
kb4 qui rode
et voilà bon et peut-être que oui
c'était enfin l'ensemble aussi mais en
tout cas c'était l'explication de Guy
parce qu'il se trouve que là il faut des
oui c'est spécial même si vous avez
cliqué après sur Youtube que c'était
très logique parce que tu attendais qui
Roque pour faire fujerks on a toujours
pas compris pourquoi tu fais pas H6 si
tu veux juste passer ton tour mais
oui
peu importe en fait mais
peu non mais n'importe quoi
donc bref mais oui tu peux mélanger et
le deuxième problème c'est que ça soit
un moment tu vas sortir de ta prépa ça
quoi qu'il en soit non et
en fait si tu as toujours été un peu
avant tu es pas trop chaud t'es pas
échauffé et tu risques de jouer pas trop
bien quoi c'est possible car il avait
joué ça aussi tempo et c'est possible
qu'il est inversé un réellement enfin
guéri en tout cas c'est ce qu'il a
trouvé il a tweeté je trouvais ça assez
intéressant ouais
il a fait une vraie recherche pour
trouver en fait
pour essayer de comprendre il a dit ok
juste là faut des 7 c'est bon donc voilà
pour le petit le petit Insight de guéri
toujours intéressant à Aniche même si on
troll un petit peu ses fans mais
évidemment c'est quelqu'un desminement
intéressant et on lit et on écoute ce
qu'il dit parce qu'il a il a des choses
des choses à partager
mais en tout cas ça c'était une belle
recherche de sa part et ça peut vraiment
être une inversion Fab ça peut tout à
fait surtout qu'il pensait en conférence
de presse il a dit qu'il joue ça après
les conférences de presse si tu croises
qui disent bon tu vas croire au Père
Noël
et puis tu sais pas en fait mais là ça
se peut qu'il est vraiment cru en fait
ils vont pas te faire une confession à
cœur ouvert
et donc on nous demande c'est quoi les
règles si cette fête et ben il y aura
quatre parties de rapides en 25 minutes
plus 10 secondes par contre il me semble
s'il y a de deux et ben
soit c'est déjà du bled parce qu'on
diminue et si encore enfin il diminue
les cadences et puis un moment s'il y a
toujours nul nul nul bon bah il te fera
un Armageddon Armageddon ce serait beau
hein mais bon c'est improbable enfin il
y aura beaucoup de départages avant mais
qui c'est
je pense tu as envie de chialer avant la
partie
le plus important de ta vie donc c'est
quoi un Armageddon c'est
une cadence spéciale en fait c'est
toujours sur une partie où on donne un
peu plus de temps au blanc genre 6
minutes et 5 minutes au noir ou bon peu
importe ça définit dans règlement mais
par contre les Blancs sont obligés de
gagner dans le sens où s'il y a nul
c'est comme si énorme avait gagné
le stress
je suis déjà stressé et voilà
et
[Musique]
ouais tu penses comme il a passé le fou
devant du coup il en peut plus de fouger
5 ouais bon non mais je veux dire
tu as raison
je reconnais ta supériorité espagnoleque
votre façon je fais pas le poids face à
face dans l'espagnol j'ai jamais joué
j'ai pipi rien et Fab il est grand
maître international et il joue ça
depuis qu'il est gamin donc et pas que
et pas que
ouais bon
expert non plus de ouf mais
mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que sur
je sais même pas fait fouger 5 mais
c'est un quoi regarde
juste avec le cavalier en D2 et tout ça
m'impressionnait moins mais parce que en
fait souvent tu reprends du Fou quoi
mais bon on se la dit voilà mais après
tu voudrais échanger et
on va voir si tu fais quel H2 qui avait
là qui avait dit là ou si tu passes
l'autre à la place de ta tour bon ça
peut ressembler à ce scénario là qu'il a
trop vu dans le match et de toute façon
H6 c'est pas si mal c'est toujours pas
il faut être fuite G6 de toute façon
harmonieux donc ça rentre dans le dans
le plan n donc c'est
[Musique]
c'est toi qui le dis je suis pas sûr
fais attention
ouais
c'est bien ça la raison ça
sur OK partir
quelqu'un à la maison changer les règles
mais du coup
si personne
à noter que ça va au départage ah il y a
moins de différence c'est au départ je
gagnais on gagne moins 1,1 contre 1,2 et
le perdant ah mais c'est bon en fait il
va vraiment pas que il y ait d'argent en
jeu en fait
parce que je trouve que la différence
elle est assez minime déjà mais bon
après pourquoi pas mais la 900000 un
million 100 bon
ça changerait rien mais sauf le titre en
fait c'est tellement d'argent après oui
oui bien sûr
ce qu'on évaluation devant vous alors
nous on a une petite turbinette qui
tourne donc notre évaluation elle vaut
pas grand chose mais non mais c'est
équilibré je suis à 100 % sûr que c'est
c'est mes 0,00
[Musique]
est-ce qu'une vidéo bilan de champion du
monde avec Vlad est prévu pour sur ta
chaîne alors pas du tout mais je pense
que on aura fait quand même le tour là
du Championnat du Monde une fois qu'il
sera fini
je pense qu'on va pas refaire un énième
bilan
parce que ça veut faire le bilan le
bilan de fab
[Musique]
voilà après
le fabilan
ça peut être un live ou on se revoit les
parties et s'il y a des questions des
machins en les moments forts mais en
gros ça serait juste une vidéo qui se
répète par rapport à ce qu'il y a déjà
je sais pas si c'est utile quoi surtout
quand c'est pour se répéter on sait déjà
beaucoup répété parce qu'on a dit en
live qu'on a répété en vidéo qu'on a
répété j'ai l'impression que
c'est compliqué
non par contre on fera peut-être un best
of ouais ça oui ça oui on fera un best
of
est-ce qu'on a ce qu'on a trouvé
intéressant bah là on a pas trop le
temps de regarder en fait mais ça doit
être intéressant j'imagine
j'imagine que ça doit être intéressant
quoi donc les analyses dikaru oh
probablement je pense que c'est
probablement intéressant et ben là après
quand tu passes 10 11 heures par jour
sur le Championnat du Monde tous les
jours au bout d'un moment bon
du coup nous on a pas le temps de
regarder mais
j'imagine que c'est intéressant
c'est une valeur
je suis pas sûr que ce soit toujours
juste il a le droit de se tromper lui
aussi mais quand même c'est intéressant
quoi qu'il en soit et on va toujours
apprendre des choses je préfère le
Hikaru qui parle d'échec que celui qui
fait des event caritatif personnellement
oui quand il parle d'échec là je suis
intéressé quand il fait des event
caritatifs un peu moins on va dire ça
comme ça mais quand il parle des chèques
évidemment c'est intéressant
et que d'autres sont mieux ou après j'en
sais rien Mathieu nous dit rien sont
beaucoup mieux donc bon après ça dépend
aussi à quel public concernant la stati
carreau il parle
à des gens moins experts c'est peut-être
plus pour
juste des lignes assistées d'ordi oui
cherchent vraiment la vérité et kaway
décrit plus que j'ai regardé ni l'un ni
l'autre je peux pas vous dire pour le
coup en fait il fait des analyses d'une
heure 15 donc c'est bien après nous
l'avait fait pour Carlson caryaki donc
entre 1h 1h30 mais après est-ce que
c'est mieux euh c'est différent en fait
c'est difficile de dire mieux au moins
bien parce que avoir une heure 15 pour
regarder un résumé de partir finalement
le coup j'ai envie de dire 1h15 sur la
partie d'hier moi ça me semble beaucoup
et bon le deuxième truc à dire c'est que
vu qu'on vit il est parti en live
bon c'est dur de refaire parce qu'en
fait la tourner la vidéo ok on voit le
temps que ça prend donc 1h15 mais il
faut aussi le temps de la préparer donc
après ça fait des journées de ouf quoi
enfin
ça va quoi résumé une demi-heure non
mais tu après est-ce que trop résumé tu
parles résumé parce que tu pourrais
écrire un tu pourrais faire un résumé de
4 heures par partie fin tu mettrais Vlad
je t'assure que Vlad pour être
extrêmement bien le connaître il est
capable de te faire trois heures sur la
partie non mais en fait après comment
dire il y a plus de limite après il y a
plus de limite c'est dans le sens
dans le sens quoi ou en fait soit on
résume la partie on te donne quelques
infos sur ce qui existe ou pas est-ce
qu'on pense qu'ils ont pu confondre ou
ce qu'ils auraient pu jouer d'autres ou
pour être l'amélioration après en fait
tu peux disséquer le truc et partir dans
une analyse de l'ouverture pousser loin
donc si tu veux faire une liste de 20h
tu peux aussi le faire d'ailleurs s'il
te positionner comme des fous regardez
des cadres regarder BK regarder après
j'ai tous les coups tiens dans quelle
limite qui allait H4 marche ou pas bon
bah là non mais peut-être dans d'autres
moments et voilà donc en fait les échecs
c'est un jeu très très riche et ça vaut
le coup de bien analyser mais après ce
que est-ce que Youtube c'est l'endroit
pour faire ça c'est plus des trucs de
livres ça en fait moi je trouve pour
nous on a fait les deux formes on est
deux formes enfin il y a même trois
formats qu'on a fait mais en gros il y a
deux formats qu'on fait
principalement c'est le format 25
minutes 35 minutes qu'on fait maintenant
bon après des fois c'est un peu plus
court s'il est parti à vraiment rien à
dire mais en gros on est sur le 25
minutes 35 minutes c'est celui qu'on a
pris on a aussi eu fait le format une
heure 1h30 et personnellement pour avoir
fait les deux je trouve que le 1h 1h30
est juste trop long même en termes de
concentration et de pédagogie tu
t'adresses vraiment à quasiment plus
personne en fait c'est à dire que le
format 25 35 minutes même Baky regarde
en fait qui regarde nos résumé par
exemple
mais même lui regarde pas un résumé du
Nord 15h30 c'est trop long et j'ai envie
de dire le format 25 35 minutes tu
t'es romanesque quoi c'est assez
intéressant pour que tout le monde
apprenne quelque chose tu vas pas dans
un détail de fou ouais et que tu es
quand même le temps de regarder le 1h15
j'ai un peu l'impression que c'est plus
quand même comme un cours d'échec et tu
vois par exemple c'est bien aussi mais
je trouve que ça s'adresse enfin je
préfère faire un DVD sur le pion isolé à
fond avec Vlad que faire 1h15 sur des
parties de championnats du monde je
trouve que pour les trucs d'actu ça s'y
prête pas trop en fait trop long enfin à
moins de la fin nous ça nous arrivait de
faire un autre format 25 35 qui dure 50
minutes parce que c'était une partie de
malade non mais là si la partie vaut
vraiment le coup on le fait on le fait
tu me rappelles c'est un Carlsen mvl on
voulait faire 25 35 minutes mais je
pense c'était avec Vlad donc c'était
calé sur ce format et la vidéo avait
duré 50 parce qu'il y avait trop de
choses et puis c'est comme ça c'est la
partie riche qui a plein de choses à
dire bah tant mieux enfin mais c'est pas
toutes les parties qui s'y prêtent
évidemment
D4 ok bon plus ou moins logique comme
coup
donc après voilà les questions à se
poser c'est ce que AB avant ce qu'on
faisait d'un lieu de préparer j'en sais
rien mais des quatre en soi c'est pas
assez logique
il y a pas de souci donc on bouffe
on bouffe ouais et je sais pas si je
prends du Caval du fou mais du Caval
perso
bon en fait juste alors deux mois à dire
sur la structure
mieux pour les blancs normalement mais
les Noirs cherchent le dynamisme ça va
faire marcher des seins ou les pièces
très actives le fruit 7 il est pas mal
etc et faut voir c'est les blancs
peuvent stabiliser ou pas
[Musique]
là j'en sais rien en fait double
tranchant tu te rappelles il y avait eu
cette structure il y a pas si longtemps
dans la partie Carlson carwana au
carwana avait complètement implosé
ah ok quand il est fait une gaffe très
rapidement une pièce là je peux
alors oui je sais plus comment c'est
arrivé mais d'accord
même si elle est mauvaise pour les Noirs
enfin moins bonne pour les Noirs c'est
hyper dynamique et ça c'est du double
tranchant en fait ça dépend où sont les
pièces c'est juste poser comme ça c'est
mieux pour les blancs mais après
[Musique]
mais évidemment si tu as des seins qui
passent en force bon bah t'éclates le
centre on vous met ça de tapes le roi
adverse
c'est une autre histoire si tu t'es
actives partout tu as les cahiers qui
saute en C5 etc donc faut voir
en tout cas
je pense qu'il va prendre parce que si
tu prends du Fou peut-être qu'il va
laisser 6 du coup ouais et du coup tu
recul il vient plus on s'écartes après
je sais pas moi mais je ok je crois
qu'en fait le choix d'ouverture de Yann
non mais c'est possible pour laisser
faire des seins qui est plus rien et nul
nul là non mais j'en sais rien c'est pas
mieux pour les blancs et c'est vraiment
trois résultats bah ça si tu veux faire
nul tu peux peut-être faire un résultat
mais c'est soit 1 soit 3 c'est pas
simple et puis on va voir mais oui enfin
je suis pas trop inquiet pour toi se
il m'impressionne pas des masses
quoi j'ai envie de dire ok non mais
écoute on va voir on n'est pas à l'abri
pour l'instant ça peut tourner et puis
faire des erreurs et puis avoir d'autres
choix stratégiques
mais globalement avec les Noirs je pense
qu'il a pas envie de voir les blancs
pousser des cinq
bon qui fait un double problème dans la
position c'est que si le pion blanc est
en dessin qui cloisonne le cavalier à 5
bon ça on a l'habitude mais en plus le
fou baisser est hyper mauvais aussi donc
là c'est double sanction donc tu peux
pas tolérer ça à côté nord
du coup ça paraît hyper logique de
vouloir prendre deux fois
après tu peux regarder près d'une fois
je ramène mon cavalier ou quoi mais je
veux dire prendre deux fois c'est normal
et là les blancs donc ont deux choix de
prise soit le cavalier soit le four on a
plus l'habitude de voir le cavalier mais
en même temps le fruit jamais en E3 donc
peut-être que là tu veux le justifier
comme ça j'en sais rien
[Musique]
et donc bon je sais pas qui est C4
peut-être il y a torse C8
il y a des options quoi pour les Noirs
il y a peut-être fouille fuite voilà il
y a des coujosables on pose une question
est-ce que eux prend des quatre et cinq
et jouable alors je vais y répondre
simplement déjà on peut commencer par
ses prends donc on peut éliminer la
question si on se la pose je comprends
si on prend des quatre cinq et jouable
bon déjà non parce que ça perd un pion
mais je veux dire quand bien même ce
serait quelque chose qui est possible
faudrait pas trop se poser la question
longtemps et calculer parce que de toute
façon les noirs peuvent l'interdire en
faisant les gens dans ce sens là donc
et là le recalco ouais non enfin non non
mais non mais juste enfin ça c'est une
un petit conseil pour bon j'imagine que
quelqu'un d'un peu débutant que de poser
la question en général quand on vous
attaque une pièce cherche pas trop au
début à faire des coups intermédiaires à
faire des contre menaces
juste fait le truc simple reprend ce
qu'on t'a pris évite la menace des
fantasya s'attaquer au bouge là mais
voilà après plus tard il peut arriver
que les coins intervenir soit beaucoup
plus forts et qu'on se pose la question
il faut pas que ce soit le réflexe de
base c'est
soit trop de joueurs qui en fait
quand ils sont attaqués ils prennent ça
un peu s'il recule comme une défaite
personnelle mais c'est pas grave on va
dire que ta pièce on va partir de
l'avant un jour mais j'aurais pas je
t'emmerde mais j'ai avancé F4 tu
m'attaque et j'avance
les pièces
dans la gueule quoi j'aurais pas de
défaite personnelle
j'aurais toutes mes pièces je t'attaque
fumier quoi
mais ouais en fait dire ça enfin faut
pas que ce soit le réflexe après que
vous le considériez vous irez tiens
peut-être est-ce que ça marche ou pas
pourquoi pas mais attention
je vais allonger 3 mais je passerai pas
par F1 je passerai par le cas je vais me
virer la case derrière
possible mais ça marchait pas trop mais
il était très content de faire les coins
intermédiaires mais c'est ça en fait je
comprends le truc mais c'est pas grave
de reculer une pièce attaquer et souvent
c'est mieux en fait en fait du coup
intermédiaires après quand tu es plus
fort tu les regardes systématiquement
mais
du coup de base
c'est plutôt à éviter les problèmes
après ouais la question sur CD bon je
pense qu'il va reprendre mais peut-être
qu'il veut jouer ce structure les CD 5
je sors de structure bénody mais ça m'a
l'air bizarre avec le fond B7 quoi qu'il
en soit un coin intermédiaire c'est un
coup qu'on place au milieu d'une
variante logique ça peut être un échec
ça peut être un coup qu'on place au
milieu genre là par exemple il prend
logique c'est de reprendre un coup
intermédiaire sera un coup qu'on
intercale et son idée de 5 c'est-à-dire
tiens tu mettes avec mon fou mais moi je
t'attaque le cavalier et Machin et bon
attends tu prends du coup je te prends
tu prends je te prends bon etc bon là ça
marche pas du tout mais c'est parce que
bon voilà mais donc oui c'est ça l'idée
de caler des coups comme ça au milieu
qui peuvent être oubliés par
l'adversaire est très fort justement
mais qui
marche pas souvent je passais le mot
mais à moins d'une fois sur deux en tout
cas j'étais en train de me dire qui est
ce bon escient est-ce que je connais
beau gosse bon vieux Alain
champion du monde
enfin ça va échanger ouais je pense
qu'il Yan c'est une partie qui va
s'effacer en tout cas l'ouverture et
ouais
parce que si il se prend des 5 euros qui
allait prendre un coup tu as le foot au
milieu qui peut après arriver vers F4
avec le fou B7
ça peut ça peut être des choses
gars il est pas obligé de reprendre des
quatre directement
mais évidemment faut regarder c'est pas
la fin du monde mais
non mais Yann je le sens tellement pas
là je je réminiscences du match
précédent tout le temps debout à jouer
vite
[Musique]
je pense que faire nul c'est vraiment le
Conseil
bah disons
salut de voir il doit se connaître il
doit savoir quand est-ce qu'ils tout bas
et si ce sont que c'est ça mais je joue
pas la partie enfin c'est nul quoi tu
sais faire avec les Blancs
et
tu ressouges ce soir de ma journée de
repos tu auras les Noirs une petite
souffrance la dernière mais ok tu
t'attends une partie qui joue made in va
peut-être pas prendre tous les risques
enfin tu en as déjà gagné une avec les
noirs et tu étais proche d'en gagner
deux donc ça veut dire que ça peut quoi
et si l'autre il abuse tu peux aussi
gagner avec les Noirs c'est pas
voilà enfin je sais pas faut juste
en haut oui une défaite aujourd'hui avec
les Blancs normalement ça compromet bien
les chances
et puis ça ça se sent jusque là pour le
moment il est pas dans son assiette
après comme on disait il envoie des
parpaings donc ça peut pas enfin ça peut
passer aussi mais c'est
[Musique]
derrière la ligne de fond là quand même
oui il faut qu'il fasse gaffe
ça commence à s'approcher de la ligne et
que arrondir un peu
de l'histoire
pas du tout là
garde la balle dans le cours mais c'est
vous qui il arrive
sur ses proies évident
mais il a peut-être raison mais je sais
pas j'aimerais pas laisser de dessin au
blanc avec ce fond en B7 qui a rien à
faire là
par principe après ça se regarde bien
sûr avec le F5 il a boisé en fait hier
des cinq directs des Noirs bon ce que
j'aime pas c'est de laisser le 5 moi
après ça se regarde peut-être mais
il va prendre là
des 5 je sais pas un peu checker juste
pour checker mais moi j'aime pas laisser
ça au blanc parce que en fait ça
réveille le fou qui d'un coup une belle
diagonale alors souvent les Noirs ce
qu'ils font c'est de le cloisonner avec
ça mais là je bouffe celui-là je me
donne la case et en fait c'est juste les
blancs qu'on bénéficié à fond de la
série de coups ce pion est pas terrible
le foot vit en muret très mauvais lui
bon il est bas sur le côté il va revenir
peut-être mais il fait trop rien et puis
tu vas te prendre un cavalier là qui va
pouvoir sauter ici peut-être on va
échanger lui un fou qui regarde là-bas
l'autre tu as plus de cahiers F6 du coup
du coup la dame va pouvoir venir par là
très très vite ça va dégénérer pour les
Noirs donc tu peux pas trop tu vois
enfin des cinq tu le fais si tu te rends
pas ça globalement je pense qu'il faut
qu'il livre et qu'il prenne en D4 enfin
probablement mais
je pense qu'il doit envoyer juste un
coup droit lifté normal un peu neutre
et laissez l'autre on voyait la mettre
la balle dehors non ouais vous bon bah
il continue d'échange et puis non mais
c'est ça
et tu vois mais ouais donc si il prend
des quatre qui le coup qu'elle s'attend
pour on a dit qu'il prend peut-être
on sait pas trop les deux sont
possibles après là-dessus il y a
peut-être plusieurs options pour les
Noirs faut être fuer possible qu'il y a
et ses 4 tours ici probablement même
s'il faut toujours questionner sur
celui-là c'est pas de quoi il va prendre
là tu en sais rien donc de toute façon
tu regardes parce que peut-être vous
prendre mais bon ce qu'on pensait c'est
que lui revient et nous tous
on se fait échanger mais
mais
[Musique]
ça j'aimerais pas alors l'ordi il nous
dit que c'est cool mais bon moi j'aime
pas donner la paire de foudre dans des
cas pareil enfin moi je trouve pas ça
cool
je ferai pas après je sais pas si c'est
travailler à la maison pourquoi pas mais
on s'attend plus à ça mais l'argent
c'est rien est-ce que c'est des seins
est-ce que l'autre il saute ici je pense
pas que ça puisse être près de Yann là
encore ça
parce que là en fait bon ça normalement
j'aime pas le scénario si je regarde mon
pion mais si je me fais bouffer
je pense que je peux défendre là
bonjour ça rien ok pas sûr des cinq
enfin du coup ça donne une position
bizarre compliquée mais qui peut bien
tourner pour les blancs mais là c'est
que double mais donc ça je suis pas
convaincu après si tu veux faire un truc
cool avec les Nord tranquille tu fais
peut-être fouiller
et tu prépares tu peux voir dessin vu
que maintenant le 5 est beaucoup plus
dur à réaliser donc sur un coup comme
attend je sais pas tout hein j'imagine
que c'est possible et puis si je prends
c'est lequel qui prend mais d'un coup
lui qu'est-ce qu'il fait là quoi là tu
es mieux avec les noirs
il me plaît pas donc j'en sais rien ce
qu'il faudrait faire ici et peut-être
bouger le fou et espérer espérer une
liquidation totale on écoute tous les
stocks et puis voilà
ok bon c'est mais j'ai l'impression que
les Blancs c'est ça qui j'espère en fait
ils peuvent pas beaucoup mieux
bref je suis pas très impressionné par
faut 3 après si le but c'est juste de
faire nul tu dois y arriver comme ça
nul c'est toujours bien
non mais surtout après une défaite une
défaite douloureuse d'ailleurs même
après une victoire bah après une
victoire aussi nul mais même après une
nul en fait nul c'est toujours bien
tu es toujours content non mais je crois
que c'était trop chiant qui avait dit ça
après une victoire nulle c'est bien pas
trop s'enflammer et quand tu as perdu
c'est bien aussi tu reviens donc en fait
bon puis après une nuit le bas c'est
bien aussi de toute façon
c'est que quand il perdait il était
dégoûté
quand il gagnait et quand c'était trop
d'émotion du coup il détestait perdre
mais dit quand il gagnait c'était trop
d'émotions aussi quoi donc ok juste nul
tout le temps et c'est moi tranquille
quoi je ne veux pas gagner
on dit que les autres c'est un ordi qui
dit B4 non mais ça se trouve c'est
jouable mais j'aime pas le coup
mais j'aime pas du tout franchement
ton ordi il faut le changer je pense
vous le débranchez
mais non B4 en fait cette lâche le
contrôle de la caisse C4 pour les blancs
je sais pas il y a pas là
fais gaffe quand même il est peut-être
en train de te manipuler ton ordi ah
j'ai lu un article de dingue sur les IA
qui pourrait en scred
discuter entre elles pour nous détruire
et du coup peut-être que c'est la
première preuve de ça qui est en train
d'arriver alors dit lui propose des
quatre très fort
tu sais Kevin celui qui m'utilise est
vraiment très con je lui ai dit B4 et il
a écrit dans le chat c'est pour te dire
la naïveté non mais attention
là je suis pas sûr qu'ils vont trouver
grand chose en tout cas pour l'instant
mais on a vu pas mal de films de
science-fiction de scénario ou ça peut
arriver un jour
il regarde sa feuille de partie il
essaie de se rappeler numéro de coude ça
prépare l'Amazon ouais non je crois pas
Mathieu là
mais ça peut des fois ouais c'est vrai
que tu sais 13e coup-fou B7
[Musique]
ils en regardent tellement mais là je
crois que qui sont qui jouent pas
eux-mêmes mais bon je peux pas mettre ma
couper non plus
non mais par contre ce sont pas les
désirs mais les algos qui te recommande
des trucs ou pas ça ça me gêne plus déjà
ça me rend fou déjà les algos ça me rend
fou
parce qu'il tombe ferme dans quelque
chose j'aime pas trop quoi en fait
j'aimerais mieux qu'il y en ait pas en
fait si j'avais le choix d'en prendre
pour moi ou pas après peut-être certains
aiment bien de d'avoir des
recommandations ciblées mais
à Bruce qui en parle pas mal
après pour l'instant les IA
peu que j'ai pu avoir affaire un chat
GPT ou quoi je trouve pas ça mal quoi
mais oui peut-être que ça posera des
problématiques un jour ou j'en sais rien
faut surveiller quoi
là il du coach non mais là par contre
moi je surveille vite fait enfin moi
c'est pas mon domaine de compétences non
plus
il est écouté
lui il
surveilleux Fabien il luizki appelé le F
c'était dans un dossier le F quoi et là
il compile les données
par contre très intéressant c'est
conseil dans le livre progresser aux
échecs d'ailleurs
il est vraiment très fin dans ces
conseils
c'est un très bon élément dans le monde
futur
même dans les lives de déplacer les
pièces attaquées
on peut reculer pour mieux avancer
rentrer intéressant je note ce conseil
là du coup Yann qui était entre les deux
reprises
cavalier alors
plus logique
mais aucun des deux est mal enfin je
pense que c'est c'est une histoire de
goût là enfin
on pourra critiquer aucun des deux coups
ni profondeur 44 c'est - 0,08 cavalier
prend une -0 11 faut prendre donc c'est
pas une prépa c'est pas possible
non mais Yann plus ou moins comme prévu
c'était pas notre scénario principal
mais non mais en fait soit il espérait
avoir fait vite fouger 5 et faire son
truc habituel mais qui était content de
jouer ça
soit j'en sais rien en fait mais c'est
en fait disons si je joue pour que ce
soit égal bon ok c'est qu'à jouer par
Ding ok c'est vraiment ce qu'on avait
prévu là ça permet de mettre une
pression sur le cheval qui protège le
pion donc quelque part il met une
pression sur 4 de par cavalier C4
et c'est vrai que si on fait cailler
prend C4 puis on prend
l'air faible et en fait je crois c'est
plutôt les blancs qui ont des soucis
avec 4 mais il mange de l'espace en plus
on a peut-être pas frof c'est peut-être
des enfin je sais pas on s'affaiblit les
diagonales les caleh 5 qui peuvent
rentrer un moment et des 5 ou des
dessins qui arrivent sur le football pas
protégé donc ça j'aime pas j'aime pas
mais froid et de toute façon quand on
prend puis on prend on se voit aussi la
colonne B sur B2 donc je veux dire
je crois qu'il fait un truc vraiment
bien
ça ça ça
prend des cinq
ça
ça et ça et
quand même
oui oui oui oui
ça rentre en force là-dedans très bien
et puis ça peut faire un nul assez vite
en fait du coup
ne serait pas moi je déteste ne pas
avoir la paire de fou mais bon là je
pense que si j'en avais besoin de plus
on va mais même sans plus non mais en
fait si on force
une fourchette
est-ce que ce serait pas l'heure de
regarder une petite pub mais c'est vrai
que c'est peut-être la ouais mais ça
peut rentrer dans un truc comme ça
bon
[Musique]
oui
je me perds à force de mettre des
finales de position
je pense que oui quand il prend ses
quatre serait mauvais et la ligne que
j'ai une montée à base de fouet F4 on se
laisse bouffer E4 on change sur B5 etc
etc ça peut vite segaliser
parce que ça
je sais pas du goût de jouer avec les
Blancs
non non parce que tu gagnes un pion
les cases noires c'est un peu pourri il
y a le fou adverse qui pourrait venir
trôner en E5 un jour
il y a des cas où ça se passe mal ça
bon mais faut mettre la petite pause on
sait jamais ça part vite en nul donc il
faut il faut le faire maintenant à tout
de suite les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amis c'est incroyable et vous qui
fait n'importe quoi
le truc c'est l'avant de regarder qu'on
avait
[Musique]
déjà moins non
effacer
foutu mais comme il joue dans ce genre
de situation de du match ça risque
d'être très rapide
donc j'ai envie de dire ça peut faire
non pas chute mais ça peut faire Ding
non mais là le problème en fait c'est
quand tu as fait H3 tu veux pas faire F3
bon ça c'est hyper connu parce que tu as
un trou en G3 talké qui peut venir
dessus et tu as deux trous ici que tu
auras beaucoup de mal à couvrir c'est
horrible tu as des cases noires qui sont
défoncés bon déjà pour parler de ce côté
tu peux te prendre du dessine CO dans la
tronche tu as le fond en l'air tu as la
colonne B avec du pressing sur sur B2
enfin ça ressemble à rien enfin c'est
horrible
mais attention s'il te plaît partie de
très haut niveau de Yann F3 vraiment
parce que toi tu es que 2500 tu as été
2540 Fides tu ne peux pas comprendre la
profondeur
3 Fabien c'est une finale de championnat
du monde
à genoux toi ça pensait que ça
l'interview assis sur le comment c'était
déjà
interview assieds-toi
tapis ou je sais plus comment ah
faudrait que je le retrouve il y a un
short là dessus assez connu le truc je
suis pas
très calé
hyper connue
non mais là en fait j'ai bah c'est
dommage en fait pour un époque qui était
si proche hier de champion du monde et
qu'il a ça remet pas et qui fait qui
fait absolument n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui quoi
et là
ça excuse-toi par terre tout de suite
par terre
à quatre pattes ouais ou un truc comme
ça après
pardon maître
mais là c'est pas beau alors après
peut-être que par miracle qui va s'en
sortir mais bon je vois pas pourquoi
Ding lâcherait la proie si facilement là
il a
il a un méga cadeau qui veut faire
mais c'est
affreux
c'est horrible n'importe quoi
une suite quoi faut pas juste faire ça
en est en quasiment pas réfléchi et puis
là tu fais F3 mais
pas du coup pourquoi tu fais des quatre
enfin en fait je sais pas comment vous
dire
parce qu'en fait là quand tu fais des
quatre mots courant que le mec est pas
con il va se laisser faire ça
donc tu regardes quand même ce qui se
passe là-dessus pour maquiller ces
quatre ça peut être un coup en fait
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons
peut-être pour lequel on n'a pas trop de
fautes en espagnol c'est un cava est là
touche le foot touche le pion alors que
c'est en C1 tiens viens je peux te
dégager quand je veux et je viens sur
cette diagonale donc il y a peut-être
une raison aussi bon peu importe
admettons mais ça faut regarder mais si
ça t'a pas regardé et que tu en conclu
tu fais F3
c'est pas possible quoi juste fait pas
des quatre en fait c'est pas grave
je sais pas quoi mais surtout que
l'autre variante dont je t'ai parlé avec
[Musique]
il fait tellement n'importe quoi tu m'as
dit à la pause il est capable de faire
qui est français 4 F3
c'est malheureux pour lui parce
qu'évidemment c'est un digne de ce qu'il
est capable de produire quand il joue
bien mais là tu mets avec le blanc
alors pourquoi être assez nul mais je
viens de l'expliquer alors regarde la
structure de ta fête comme ça tu te fais
un trou là tu te fais des trous sur
toutes les cases noires tu contrôle plus
tu laisses le four en prise
et donc tu peux te prendre des dessins
qu'à tout moment en fait donc il a juste
fait faux effets tranquillou prépare des
cinq prépares des petites tactiques et
qui ait des cinq le fruit pas protégé
donc tu as des problèmes là-dessus tu as
l'autre qui peut sauter la dame qui
passe
la colonne tu t'es autour ouverte en
échangeant en C4 j'ai reçu n'importe
quoi en fait évidemment le jour où tu
prends ça tu fais froid de toute façon
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire d'autre tu
vas pas donner ton pion mais
peut-être mais je veux dire il a pris la
décision à ce moment-là mais en fait
soit tu vois ça attends gros je
t'explique comment tu vas jouer aux
échecs tu vois ça tu te dis bon je suis
peut-être je vais se défendre peut-être
pas mais c'est la merde bon tu dis ce
que j'ai pas autre chose tu dis bon j'ai
quand même pas envie de me faire doubler
les pions tiens si j'esquive attention
je perds un pion mais pas vraiment parce
que là tu es capable de voir ça attaque
le cavalier quand il circule ah merci
pour le fouet on rentre de trois coups
c'est dans ses cordes ça va il va le
voir donc pas qu'elle prend V2
bah quoi d'autre quoi d'autre ce qui me
prend ça et donc il va prendre d'abord a
priori je vais reprendre il me bouffe un
pion ok il me bouffe un pion j'ai un
pion de moins ah mais en fait ça va je
regagne champion de moi bon il a été
matérielle j'attaque à trois fois
celui-là quand même
et là tu juges ça tu te dis
bon c'est pas ouf mais bon a priori il y
a une chance de que le reposer
bon ça fait nul
et en fait donc tu compares cette
position tu as le choix tu peux voir ça
ou ça
mais facile c'est pas des calculs de ouf
tu le vois en 20 secondes
mais c'est juste que tu as pu lucidité
en fait c'est pas un problème de d'autre
chose tu peux plus jouer aux échecs en
fait là quand tu fais ça tu peux plus
aux échecs donc je suis très inquiet sur
ce qui va nous proposer par la suite
très franchement c'est nettement en
dessous du niveau d'un Fab en tournant
par exemple là ce que fait n'est pas oui
oui c'est pas bien
explosé mais comme au dernier match lui
donner des pièces en un enfin c'est
exactement bises répétita mais
il peut juste plus jouer aux échecs en
fait ça arrive il peut juste jouer aux
échecs
tu te connais donc il sait qu'il est
dans cet état mais ne joue pas la partie
fais une vente forcée de nul va dans
tu joues à Marshall et tu fonces dans la
finale du Marshall et tu fais nul bah
c'est c'était ma proposition de ce matin
et du coup tu dors ce soir demain tu te
changes un peu les idées de toute façon
si tu peux pas jouer après demain bah de
toute façon c'est pareil enfin autant te
laisser la chance de revenir dans le
match avec deux jours de repos plutôt
que de dès aujourd'hui peindre quoi
[Musique]
on se met sur la gueule
non mais
on se met sur la gueule quoi 14 parties
mettez-vous sur la gueule les amis en
fait tous les noms le seul problème
c'est que là mais faut que dingue c'est
pas faire par rapport aux autres
comme
Voice
je veux ma chance pour le titre quoi et
ta Magnus qui vient et tapez vous dessus
quoi
Ding bag news allez let's go quoi
enfin un vrai match mais bon écoute
[Musique]
s'en sortir je n'y crois pas beaucoup je
veux dire là vu la série d'aller
sciemment là-dedans ou que Magnus aille
au candidats qu'il les gagne
sur la gueule quoi
je suis chaud la femme que les deux se
foutent dessus quoi
non mais c'est comme là-bas tu as envie
tu sais c'est comme tu as la box tu as
des méchants quand tu as un qui arrive
machin et tu as envie de les voir au
bout d'un moment on est plus méchant
qui se tape dessus quoi
c'est pour créer des bons combats là tu
sens que nepo bon bah ok il est pas
assez fort il se fait écraser on le
coule mon lui aurait pu jamais le revoir
allez hop ça dégage toi on te fait plus
jamais donc on fait plus à mon combat tu
veux jouer les candidats non toi tu ne
joueras pas tu as pas le droit tu en
veux plus voir ta gueule et on te met
digne on te met mal nuit si on les
enferme dans une salle on les laisse on
voit ce qu'il en sort quoi et après on
va chercher les petits jeunes ou quoi ou
d'autres qui
mais écoute on va voir je sais pas si si
jamais il te sauve cette partie
peut-être ça te le remettra dedans mais
j'attends qu'on a trop vu ça dans le
dernier match
non qui se foutent sur la gueule
allez let's go let's go du Ding let's go
du Magnus et let's go se foutent sur la
gueule ça ça va être sympa on a trop vu
ça bon en tout cas il a fait fou F2 qui
est logique bah il reste pas dans les
avis de la tour mais bon bah les 15 mars
sont pourris quoi
il pleure il entendait mais bon parce
qu'elles ont la marre de dépôt quoi elle
veut avoir Ding Magnus qui se foutent
dessus quoi non mais la pauvre petite
elle a trois mois et demi elle voit ça
en bas du championnat du monde elle en
peut plus quoi enfin il fait fève trois
fois
c'est comme dans les films tu prends les
plus méchants au bout d'un moment
il s'appelait elle était les films avec
Van Damme
[Musique]
tout le temps
tu as un combat d'ailleurs mais là genre
tu as un combat au milieu entre deux
ploucs enfin ça nous intéresse pas enfin
passez-moi finir là
Magnus premier degré il décharding
[Musique]
on voit le quoi envoie-le on verra enfin
je veux dire un match
là pour le match qui se foutent dessus
quoi mais non mais c'est ça qui est beau
dans les échecs c'est que ça retrouve un
peu de ces ce côté combat quoi que la
conférence de presse machin enfin il
s'insulte quoi il y a jamais mais qui
est quoi
ce pleutre de vie King qui n'est pas
venu hommage volume
à la boxe aux échecs je vais lui dire sa
grand-mère vas-y et l'autre il vient
quoi comment tu as parlé tu vois c'est
qui se mette quoi ouais ça m'a chauffé
là c'est c'est non mais ah il prend
thème pour mon dessin non mais il a
raison de quoi jouer mais
réfléchites toi quoi
bah toi mais des barbelés de partout
complètement abattu oui mais je vois
mais c'est pas l'attitude mais les
barbelés et puis tant pis et force
l'adversaire a bien joué pour te battre
non en fait tu
[Musique]
mais il faut plus mal jouer maintenant
on est à la limite quoi
mais j'aime pas il joue trop vite enfin
je veux dire le couvent encore
tout d'un coup tous les parfums passent
quoi non il tient la nul non non
tu fais une connerie tu oublies un truc
tu
peux redonner la pièce comme l'autre
fois en fait enfin il peut refaire ce
genre de truc il est pas dans son état
quoi
il est pas objectivement il est pas
perdant c'est juste c'est n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi et là je vais de bons
coups mais au hasard en fait c'est il
tombe bien oui c'est bon ils sont
logiques en même temps
va pas trop quoi
je sens pas au combat quoi après le seul
truc positif c'est que la position elle
s'est quand même bien simplifiée et même
si t'es pas trop dedans mais il y a des
tactiques qui vont tomber dame G5 le
caca F4 les tours ressemblent en D8 et 8
ou 3 B8
le foot canard qui va revenir vers tu
vas te prendre des attaques tu vas pas
pouvoir jouer des coups simples et
changer il va il va falloir défendre
s'il y a des sacrifices qui marchent
sans H3 sur des tours je sais pas enfin
ça va arriver de tous les côtés KF4 qui
est des trois qui saute
ramener lui la tête à Magnus comme ça
les gens ils vont m'écrire la tête de
Magnus
[Musique]
tu sais pas parler français
et ils ont trouvé un titre si Ligue des
champions du monde à pied
[Musique]
il doit être très heureux
qu'est-ce que j'ai bien fait de ne pas
faire nos travaux là-dessus quoi ah oui
parce qu'il aurait dit qu'il n'est pas
pair et ça aurait peut-être changé le
cours mais je vais lui dire nostrav la
nuit ça a toujours
écrit il réjouit une époque il doit être
tellement heureux Vlad
je pense que Vlad en ce moment il est
chez lui en calebute en train de faire
ça
mais bon il doit quand même avoir un
tout petit peu peur d'avoir une grosse
déception si jamais
en train de faire un peu ça quoi yo yo
yo yo yo les fines fleurs
le bon côté pour Ding qui est mal déjà
la pendule parfois c'est là il a quand
même 1h24 il y en a déjà joué un coup
donc là il est très large
et là en plus il pense à se balader il
doit être en train d'analyser en solde
de repos tu imagines
je veux dire je sais pas quoi
c'est que bon moi je peux parler parce
que je connais un peu les Indiens quoi
mais dans ce genre de position j'ai
juste faire un truc
je fais ça je fais ça je fais 5 mais là
vers tout le monde sait que tu dois
faire tout le monde sait mais tu le sais
depuis toujours et personne fait deux
mais pourquoi personne ne fait fou et
deux parce que quand tu bouffes tu
apprécies tu vas faire tout re 8 tu vas
faire que tu vas y aller et tu vas
forcer les blancs à te faire F3 un jour
et en fait personne ne veut jouer avec
les Blancs parce que tu as ce pion et
franchement on serait pas comme ça et on
serait avec faut deux et on ferait ça et
hérak et ça il faut trois et prise prise
et tout 8 bon mais ça ça dérange
personne de faire froid enfin au pire tu
fais dames et deux ou je sais pas tu
réfléchis mais F3 là c'est pas grave
parce que il y a plus les trous si tu as
besoin de faire j'ai trop un jour pour
contrôler tu vas le faire etc mais en
fait je veux dire bon mais ça c'est pas
une trouvaille j'en ai et c'est vrai
dans les stades c'est vrai dans les
pires que c'est vraiment plein de trucs
que dans les quand il y a squash 3 d'un
coup elle prend des ça devient une une
possibilité pour les Noirs mais là quand
même on voit on voit la similitude c'est
que lui il est déjà là on a dans la
partie mais tu veux surtout pas avoir à
faire ça
mondial parce que maintenant pour avoir
le droit de parler tu as l'impression
que ça pas été champion du monde tu peux
plus rien dire qui dit c'est une il a
dit à 1h donc avant le F3 et tout il a
dit c'est une décision très étrange de
la part de Yann d'aller pour un grand
combat après le désastre d'hier j'ai
l'impression que le match est peut-être
déjà terminé de facto il a tweet avant
le F3
une emoji en mode mais enfin pourquoi tu
joues quoi
en fait il y a pas que nous il y a tout
le monde en fait personne comprend ce
qu'il fait non mais il craque
mentalement si on comprend mais juste le
problème en fait c'est que mais il est
entouré il a une équipe comment son
coach il lui dit en fait tu le sais que
tu craques tu le sais tu l'as déjà vécu
dans ta vie en fait tu es donc tu
comprends avant la partie que tu es dans
cet état de qui va pas et tu as les
connaissances pour faire nul avec les
Blancs même si un câble de jouer tu
joues une prépa qui fait nul donc certes
tu rentres dans le Marshall par exemple
donc le Marshall pour ceux qui
connaissent pas hein
petite digression c'est une vente de
l'espagnol en fait c'est le nom d'un
ancien joueur qui s'appelait Franck
Marshall
donc tu fais tourner pour défendre ton
pion il te fait ça tu t'en vas irok
tu fais ces trois il fait des cinq et
c'est une variante bah bien réputée pour
les mains il donne un pion mais il y a
beaucoup de jeux mais en fait il y a un
tas de trucs où tu joues des coups force
enfin tu joues la théorie et ça finit
également et voilà mais au pire tu es
dans cet état tu fais ça tu proposes
rien tu fais nul en 45 minutes et puis
on en parle plus c'est quand même mieux
que que ça quoi qu'il arrive
après la seule chose qui peut le sauver
c'est que Ding se fout en PLS total
parce qu'il est proche de devenir
champion du monde là quand même
avec ça je vois qu'il perdait
parce qu'il peut être complètement
rattrapé par l'enjeu et nous faire une
chokada mais franchement j'ai envie de
voir des partages entre les deux ça peut
être une choque Adam et internationale
ouais bon ben là
ah ça peut être extraordinaire Fab ça
peut être ce battlek ça l'est déjà un
petit peu mais là les départages d'une
épo ça peut être
ça peut aller très très loin ça peut
être extraordinaire quand ils sont
capables de faire des coups comme F3 ou
quoi ça peut être waouh c'est la seule
battle avant l'heure quoi non mais là je
pense que Ding il va pas laisser passer
l'occasion
en fait je sais pas Ding il m'a pas
donné l'impression d'être tellement
rattrapé par l'enjeu
non non
en fait juste je sais pas il a un
problème de je pratique mais la plus
faite plus il joue plus chaud moins il
fait le coin avec la pendule hier
ils sont capables les deux sont capables
de nous offrir un spectacle digne des
plus grands là non mais Nadine il doit
il doit gagner enfin en tout cas il doit
être en difficulté et si une époque
défend parfaitement qui est bravo mais
je vois pas pourquoi d'un coup il faut
saisirait à ce moment-là après avoir
fait ça depuis ça peut être le cirque
Pinder
j'espère pas j'ai juste envie de voir au
moins un des deux bien joué et faire une
belle partie de la table tu as pas envie
de voir une pinte des rade
à Saint-Étienne
ou pas
[Musique]
de partie de peintre
le grand chef sur la semaine prochaine
avec Yann
il peut faire deux sur neuf mais il a
pas envie voilà en fait qu'est-ce qu'il
va faire là-bas il va te dégoûter il va
se taper la tête contre les murs il veut
pas voir ça quoi ah ça peut être ça peut
être il va jouer tout un pot il peut se
faire pindered quoi il peut il peut se
retrouver à 27 50 à la fin du tournoi et
en fait ça peut être extraordinaire en
fait je crois que les autres pour le
battre il se fait juste falloir lui
jouer des un peu pas théoriques juste tu
te fais par réciter
et il va te prendre des décisions à la
con parce que ça va l'énerver n'importe
quoi
ça peut faire plaisir pour Maxime à
l'irezas ça peut être des fripounts
gratuits
faut les prendre quand il tombe cela
pourquoi on part comme c'est perdu bah
non pas du tout moi je suis pour le
cirque Pinder Fab il espère là
maintenant que Ding réussi à jouer une
partie correcte pour se mettre un peu
quelque chose sous la dent efficacement
parlant et moi j'espère que ce soit
nawak et qui est gaffe sur gaffe en fait
on n'est pas tout à fait dans la même
team avec sa femme espère avoir des bons
coups moi j'espère voir des enfin moi
j'espère que Ding it show qui les change
tout et qu'il fasse nul quoi non mais là
il a pas envie là
mais deux objectifs qui s'entendent
Tim Pinder ouais moi je suis team mais
en fait de base j'étais chaud pour avoir
des partages mais
je sais pas comment dire que genre
aujourd'hui n'est pasissais que dans
deux jours il est avec les noirs et
qu'il y ait pas ok mais normal quoi mais
une fois que je vois ça j'ai quand même
la partie
voilà qui gagne la partie aujourd'hui
avec les noirs et qui recoulante
déjà aujourd'hui que il y en a un des
deux qui gagnent mais encore avec pas
mal de conneries pas que ce soit non il
faut qu'il y en ait encore
keV c'est clairement le malheur des un
film aux autres mais c'est pas vraiment
ça c'est que les mecs façon ils sont
payés 2000000 pour un truc ou
normalement on s'ennuie un peu donc là
au moins qui touche 2 millions mais qui
nous fasse rire tu vois je sais pas
c'est un peu
ça c'est un peu comme le cirque quoi
c'est un peu tal clown qui passe quoi tu
as les trapézis les Magnus les machins
et tout d'un coup venez voir nos
dresseurs nos machins et venez voir
diminuer et Yann des pommiers
le nez rouge machin et il clique quoi tu
es là ouais il est marrant celui-là
refait un match tiens toi ça se met une
prochaine au grand chaise Tours où ils
vont jouer avec ce signe que fait le
grand chasseur a besoin de dingly Rennes
et nine et en une semaine ils viennent
avec rapporte leurs entraîneurs qui
jouent aussi ouais ils viennent avec des
mais il va être il va être fort il te
rapporte cette fille
cracheurs de feu les mecs se mettent des
épées dans la bouche on est parti allez
jongleurs ils arrivent là quoi les
dresseurs d'ours et puis ils sont là
quoi
mais c'était les bonnes qui avaient dit
the chelse Circus que il avait fait ça
aussi Circus les grandes chaises sont
assez tu as le vrai cirque quoi
de mettre de cérémonie tu as défilé sous
les sous les échiquets sur les mecs se
jettent tiens un truc très très
romanesque quoi
vous avez dit moi enfin je pencherai
pour dame G5 comme Fab mais après ça
demande un peu de calcul non mais là il
calcule en fait il veut là il calcule il
veut tuer quoi
tu peux comme dire tes disto tu peux
envoyer deux trois vachettes aussi ah
bah oui
chèque est extraordinaire mais
ni après on est très serre parce que
l'ordinateur vient instantanément la
valeur des coûts sans ordinateur sur la
c'est très différent alors non
franchement la F3 enfin prends pas FAF
pour un con quand même enfin tu vois
5 minutes de nous prendre quand même
pour des bolins enfin j'arrive quand
même grand maître Fab respecte un petit
peu enfin je veux dire que Fab son
ordinateur il comprend pas avec F3 c'est
mauvais c'est quand même un manque de
respect ça peut valoir ban c'est non
mais c'est clairement manque de respect
là j'arrive trois c'est quand même
faut pas manquer de respect à Fab non
plus quoi
gagner mais en tout cas que F3 soit
affreux j'ai pas besoin d'ordi quoi non
mais bon il te manque de respect
non mais vraiment
vous comprenez que enfin ok il se trouve
qu'on a l'ordi donc on peut voir la
barre qui saute qui descend mais
enfin des fois on s'est quand même deux
trois trucs de base quoi et quand il y a
des coups qui sont vraiment pas bon on
vous le dit quoi
alors des fois c'est pas bon pour des
raisons obscures des coups d'ordi parce
que il y a une pointe après 15 coups bon
le dieu aussi en fait et on l'a dit
mais en fait de te jouer avec un
triangle vers l'arrière à des cases
noires pourries mais je veux dire tu le
sais enfin tu le sais je t'ai montré les
indiennes en fait je t'expliquais donc
je te dis prends pour un ballon les mecs
te manque de respect gratuitement quoi
c'est terrible
donc ça quoi mais ne possède en fait
tout le monde sait mais oui bien sûr
ça va il est 2008 il a gagné deux fois
les candidats c'est pas c'est pas un
débile quoi mais là il est dans un état
mental qu'il arrive plus quoi il peut
plus jouer ouais non il peut plus jouer
c'est mais ça nous est arrivé c'est
horrible quand ça arrive c'est horrible
3 c'est super bravo nepo mais c'est un
coup de merde c'est un coup de merde
voilà bon c'est comme ça
mais c'est pas c'est jamais contre
l'homme en fait que je dis ça et c'est
pas contre le joueur non plus c'est que
aujourd'hui il joue mal bon bah hier
aussi mais que bon la plupart du temps
c'est quelqu'un qui joue bien et mieux
que moi mieux que nous et bien sûr
mais je veux dire c'est comme quand
des notes au joueur dans l'équipe des
joueurs de foot bon mais je sais pas des
fois ils ont deux
mais ok c'est il a pas deux chaque
semaine tout le temps ils sont quand
même trop de foot ils savent deux trois
trucs mais si tu fais un match de merde
tu te fais dribbler à chaque fois que tu
marques ton camp que je sais pas enfin
ok qu'on va pas te dire bravo ouais
dommage mais tu sais pourquoi il a pas
défendu parce que il a compris un truc
toi tu comprends pas mais non enfin
c'est juste que il a mal joué ce jour-là
quoi mais c'est tout en fait et ça
arrive de mal jouer mais ok on va pas en
français quelqu'un qui joue mal mais
c'est pas méchant non plus c'est
objectif sur ce qu'on voit quoi bon bah
F3 ça va pas et je vous conseille de pas
jouer comme ça aux échecs vos propres
parties après bah faites-le je crois que
c'est bien moi je m'en fous c'est pas
mes parties c'est les vôtres en fait
donc voilà
c'est fait à 3 B2 c'est 3 en tout est
parti mais c'est bien enfin et puis on
verra bien mais
alors pourquoi l'ordi tu es le meilleur
coup bah
je sais pas une colonne et il tape le
pion voilà donc ça se considère
ça se considère même G5 ça se considère
parce que tant bien tu regardes le pion
B2 tu défends ton fou B7 donc le pied
des 5 va pouvoir naviguer vers F4 vers
BK direction Detroit effectivement si tu
changes ton fou baisser contre le fouet
4 et que tu plantes la cavalier en D3
pieuvre
on dit ça bah remis l'église au milieu
de l'échiquier ouais Fab il a posé tu as
posé des balles non mais je sais pas
poser des bases mais là c'est
genre de mec dans un parc qui crie bah
histoire avec ce n'est à peine à
bousculer mais en fait moi mon père mon
père en fait il est restaurateur il
avait plutôt un bar et donc c'est vrai
que j'ai pu vivre beaucoup de
discussions de bistrot quand j'étais
quand j'étais gamin moi j'adore en fait
c'était là tu es au bar tu as des mecs
qui te chauffent vraiment je suis là je
suis je suis très très bien là je suis
moi je suis aux anges comment ça parler
un peu fort et puis bon tout de suite
après quand ça parle fort ça prend
vraiment l'accent du sud
tu as pas d'accent quoi
le lendemain il y a pas de problème mais
c'est cool quoi
ouais c'est une colère saine
donnez-moi un micro
qui arrive pas regarde il y a un micro
là je vais répondre
comme dit bravo
en même temps c'est c'est vrai
mais on va voir
[Musique]
il a buggé
en or je pense qu'il rêvait pas aussi
bien avant la partie bon tu sais que là
en fait si tu fais bien tu es quasi
champion du monde donc ça a une valeur
les coups que tu vas jouer
et voilà quoi
on parle de respect qu'on s'attaque une
époque sur son physique
ouais moi je sais pas ça réfléchit
non mais voilà il réfléchit dame j'ai 5
tours B8 et peut-être encore d'autres
options
après c'est deux coups qui enfin moi
dame j'ai 5 qui me une petite fille mais
je peux pas dire sur le meilleur coup
d'ailleurs bon leur dit que tu as envie
de plus fort donc déjà voilà mais je
pense qu'en fait il doit prendre en
priorité d'âme G5 parce que dans la
dernière dame vers le roi de voir ce qui
allait F4 tu fais très mal ou pas
mais changer les dames est-ce que j'ai
une suite ok bon t'as pas envie
d'échanger tu te dis le adverse il est
quand même un peu faible on va voir
c'est bizarre parce que mais bon
je sais pas je peut-être que le temps
non mais en fait j'aimerais qu'il
défende bien que Ding joue bien
l'attaque et que non mais enfin soit il
gagne bien parce qu'il y a une bien et
puis il va rien faire soit qu'au pire ni
nul mais j'ai que de voir des beaux
trucs
en tout cas c'est là c'est impossible de
prédire le scénario de la partie là
c'est impossible
non c'est pas mais chaque coup peut être
une erreur enfin c'est c'est hyper
intéressant
mais du coup madame G5 alors c'est quoi
la
du coup des blancs
moi je pense à H4 mais bon
ça a l'air beau hein
et juste pour savoir c'est quoi les
numéros en octobre 8
5 c'est
en fait tu veux partir sur
aussi mais
c'est pas facile ton B8 non non c'est
pas facile parce que tu as trois tiré
par M G5
c'est de bouger ce qu'il y avait les
vers des trois c'est dur et évidemment
si tu forces pour prendre des seins et
que tu prends en plus avantage de la
paire de fou en plus de tout ce qu'on a
dit
le fou B7 sera incontesté
très très fort il peut se planter un
dérange un jour tu peux réfléchir faire
G5 G4 aussi démolir le roi comme plante
petit à petit et donc ça c'est fort mais
c'est dur
s'il trouve tombé 8 c'est très c'est
très très bien joué
pour le 4 juin
bon en fait en soi c'est pas absurde
comme ça de qualité mais en fait c'est
trop risqué par rapport à ce que tu peux
avoir en risque rien tu as envie de
faire G5 mais en soi
et que tu te rediriges vers des trois je
regarde tu as des condensation de table
enfin si tu étais pas nettement mieux
avant la position ce serait correct mais
là enfin c'est un peu dommage d'ordonner
de l'incertitude à la position alors que
tu as un avantage en faisant des coups
normaux
tant B8 faut j'ai trop espèce quoi la
question je me suis posée la même
question
[Musique]
à fout des quatre en plus enfin même pas
qu'on fait un très tôt d'ailleurs
donc ça va pas
ouais
mais peut-être que ça a être aussi
proche de perdre ça pue le détendre
après ne plus avoir de pression avoir
complètement lâché c'est pas forcément
bien pour jouer non plus il faut un peu
de stress aussi donc là mais bon je
comprends pas la fin honnêtement
je comprends qu'il puisse mal jouer et
qu'il soit pas en état de jouer mais ce
sont là pourquoi avoir essayé de jouer
parce qu'il le savait et on l'a déjà vu
qu'on de Magnus le match d'avant et
peut-être parce qu'il a accepté de
perdre et du coup il se détend
mais
tu es loin de perdre
le titre je souffle je prends mes 800000
balles
je vais jouer en
masse volumique
mais je sais pas en fait
il est pas solide il a pas
il aura un pion c'est de là tu fais le
pion c'est trop après tu gardes ton
cahier en décalque il rayonne là j'ai
peur
avec sch et
pour
mais ce qui est des catch je suis pas
sûr qu'on le stabiliser longtemps si on
se le reprend pas si
plus le G5 G4 qui arrive pour tout
ouvrir
c'est simplement interdit on n'a pas le
droit de noter pour les gens
parce qu'il y a eu trop de gaffes dans
ce match
on espère moi j'espère Fab non mais j'ai
envie qu'il attaque cinépo défend bien
et qui est nul je suis très content
aussi enfin je suis très content c'est
un grand mot mais
je sais pas j'ai envie que ça joue bien
le mieux possible quoi voilà tu reviens
dans kimono
il revient quoi
un peu trop loin un peu trop loin
non mais après peut-être que Ding
s'entend trop que c'est possible il va
te réfléchir une heure sur le coup il va
commencer à se stresser autant enfin oui
on a pas la partie blondation dernier
mot et c'est pas pour autant que ça
aurait été bien joué de faire froid
avant
ça
va pas c'est tout
il y aura 4 parties
du coup tu pars sur quoi toi tu dis quoi
parce que ça peut pas jouer maintenant
j'en sais rien
qu'on s'expose à foi H4 en fait il y a
un truc qui m'inquiète
je sais pas quoi
bah écoute je sais pas trop
je fous des quatre je suis pas méga
impressionné par Toro 5 mais quand il a
tellement réfléchi sur le coup que ok
d'avoir des idées intéressantes même toi
j'ai 5 fois je capte il veut du tout
rangé deux
il veut des trucs comme ça
donc
pour un con en fait tu as pas de cases
non j'avais pas du tout faut H4
j'enfilage j'avais H4 parce que c'était
la même idée contre dame G5 mais du coup
ça si tu fais toujours 5 tu te prends
foi
[Musique]
est-ce que il peut se dire tiens je vous
laisse avec la qualité je vous explique
comme ça mais non enfin bon je sais pas
on retourne
aussi mais je alors dis pas du tout
impressionné il y a quasiment plus
davantage mais c'est vrai juste Dame des
deux en fait ça tourne 5 elle fait quoi
elle est hyper mal placé mais ça se
trouve c'est il a pas trop
apprécier le H4
et du coup il a pas eu tomber 8 et c'est
pour ça qu'il a fait ouais j'en sais
rien
écoute on va voir de toute façon on se
rapproche de notre deuxième pause mais
c'est bizarre enfin juste le coup
visuellement il est bizarre parce que
les tours elles sont pas bien placé au
centre de l'échiquier normalement il y a
trop de pièces pour t'attaquer
et les pièces lourdes généralement ils
sont mal au centre de l'échiquier en
milieu de partie et surtout une tour en
plus parce que comme ça contrôle pas les
diagonales ça se fait facilement toucher
encore plus qu'une dame d'ailleurs et
c'est
et c'est la seule pièce qui contrôle
autant de cases ou qu'elles soient sur
l'échiquier
donc elles sont bien placés sur la 8e ou
sur la 7e pour doubler ou sur la sixième
parce qu'elles ont en appui bon là il
veut faire une tour hyper loupe mais le
problème c'est qu'elle a pas de il y a
trop de il y a pas assez de contrôle
encore
je crois qu'il va gaver je sais pas
quand car le coup est pas affreux mais
il est pas dedans enfin j'aime pas
l'attitude je suis vite sur 5 tu te fais
pas la voir comme quoi non tu peux pas
la voir et il a cliqué en deux minutes
quoi mais en fait il se trouve le coup
est pas si mal parce que c'est un bon
joueur de rapide mais
je sais pas
à la partie elle est ouais mais c'est
les nerfs des deux qui explosent en fait
ils implosent tous les deux
après je sais pas enfin de temps d'avoir
parce que peut-être que vraiment il a
pas vu
mais
peut-être c'est pas
je peux dire moins de mal de Tours 5 de
F3 quoi mais ouais mais ça sent quand
même
non c'est moins pire que froid parce
qu'elle fera c'est sûr c'est sûr à 100%
que c'est mauvais mais tu ressens que ça
quand même une mauvaise tête
un peu mieux non encore
5 c'est bizarre c'est pas une question
d'ordi les amis c'est juste qu'on voit
que enfin est-ce que enfin citez-moi des
parties ou les où on met des tours comme
ça en plein milieu de l'échiquier c'est
rare ici en fait c'est pas une question
d'ordi c'est des trucs qu'on a appris
quand on avait 7 ans quand même de pas
mettre les tours au centre en milieu de
partie c'est pas c'est on n'a pas eu
besoin de l'ordinateur pour le savoir
vous nous prenez vraiment pour des
bulles en fait vous prenez pour des cons
c'est incroyable
c'est juste incroyable on nous prend
vraiment pour des cons Fab alors
peut-être moi encore plus que toi mais
toi aussi quand même dans le mouvement
mais
c'est pas grave pour ce que vous voulez
en fait on s'en fout en fait
des tours 5 faites des
fêtes F3 je crois de reparti faites
faites en fait il y a pas de problème
voilà très bien bravo à vous grand bien
vous fasse
non mais après je sais pas quoi dire
quoi
ok normal
mettez au cavalier en A5
non c'est bizarre après ça peut être bon
là c'est moins c'est moins catégorique
parce que c'est tactique mais le truc
c'est que
c'est pas évident comme coup mais tu
peux y penser après Damien 5 donne envie
mais pareil je peux pas m'avancer que ça
va gagner au cas mais c'est du coup mais
clairement Ding a passé beaucoup de
temps à réfléchir donc dame G5 qui
devait
avoir des défenses des trucs
et la pensée que tu ressens qui
améliorer son cas ce qui peut être le
cas ou pas le cas concrètement après que
le coup une tronche bizarre ça oui une
tranche bizarre
même on l'avantage des noirs est quand
même assez net et assez stable en tout
cas pour le moment donc ça peut aller
mais après le tour c'est un tempo c'est
non mais c'est ça
il réussit à rien faire il va gagner
enfin un peu comme hier en fait genre le
fouet 4 fougée de tous deux là qu'on a
aimé c'était bien parce que ce qu'on
avait dit on a dit tu fais rien tu
laisses l'autre imploser et là le truc
c'est qu'il a moins une position où il
peut le faire
je trace c'est bon ben je crois que tu
t'exposes toujours à cavalue 3
[Musique]
mais est-ce que c'est grave et tu peux
faire Adam c'est deux après peut-être le
fouet juste mal il prend la case quand
même mais en fait c'est devenu tout d'un
coup tactique quoi la position c'est à
dire que il y a des trucs qui vont
marcher ou pas marcher concrètement
mais il va falloir bien
ça vaut quoi j'aime pas trop parce que
j'ai une handical F4 mais je suppose que
je la soit H7 et tout repenser 4 en fait
je fais juste une double attaque
j'ai le droit de faire cinq ou pas
c'est pas brillant après la difficulté
des evalles dans cette position c'est
que les noirs sont mieux partout mais il
y en a sûrement des positions où ils
sont pas mieux enfin c'est un effet
d'optique et il y en a d'autres ou s'en
est pas un c'est pour ça que c'est dur à
juger après bon il faut pas qu'il se
mette trop mal à l'aise au pire il y a
une paille pas enfin faut juste pas
qu'il la perdre on se positionne quoi
tu poses
et Tourer tu vois je veux changer des
trucs
pour moi ça semble faire quand même pas
mal sens
leur dit à ne pas trop mais j'aurais
vraiment envisagé ça
parce que je serais dit je m'échange un
truc qui sert à rien contre le truc au
milieu là qui dégage et après je vais
essayer de te mettre la dame en E2 et
commencer enfin
je sais pas j'aurais l'impression tiens
j'ai quand même changé une pierre
non mais pourquoi pas enfin je veux dire
la pensée est irrationnelle
les gens j'ai même pas envisager le coup
mais oui enfin c'est une vraie enfilade
des capacités de le faire
[Musique]
mais ouais toujours pas il joue vraiment
vite dans une position qui pourrait
mériter de longues analyses
et après je pense que lui il part du
principe que de toute façon il arrive
pas trop à réfléchir donc ça c'est
honnêtement c'est pas si bête
du coup ça te détend je sais pas comment
dire tu arrêtes de te mettre en PLS tout
seul et ça va être encore pire
et tu joues des coups
[Musique]
disons que suivant l'état dans lequel tu
es ça peut peut-être être la fin c'est
une mauvaise solution mais c'est
peut-être la moins pire de toutes celles
que tu as
parce qu'au final son clic au hasard non
mais ça va il va avoir un instant
naturel très correct mais il peut jouer
25 sur l'instinct naturel et peut-être
que 26 26 50 fit ça suffit ici pour
faire nul
donc c'est pas si
tu sais que tu joueras pas 28 mais au
moins tu joueras pas à 21 ou 22 non plus
non non non
cavalue
je sais pas trop où mais tu l'ouvres
quoi et
tu veux peut-être qu'elle va laisser
tranquille et liquider enfin je sais pas
si ça marche à calculer mais
non mais écoute si la défend
et mieux pour l'intérieur mais bon
non il s'est un peu ressaisi là Yann je
trouve
mais ça peut dégénérer chaque coup en
fait enfin pas
c'est le vrai cœur c'est Carlson en
évidence bourbier je pense pas parce que
les absents ont toujours tort
non mais ouais de toute façon
c'est juste le meilleur joueur au monde
donc il y a pas de doute mais
après si je joue pas il joue pas et puis
bah là le champion sera légitime c'est
tout
il y a pas grand chose à dire
[Musique]
rien dit que sera gagné le match après
son meilleur niveau il leur a gagné mais
bon après tu sais pas comment se passe
le match s'il peut être surpris pour une
ouverture ne pas être en forme être
malade enfin il peut se passer des
choses aussi là dans le sport des fois
tu as des gens très favoris avant un
match et puis
ce jour-là ça a pas marché
mais je sais pas enfin bon là on va plus
parler de sport individuel mais même
dans l'espoir collectifs en 2004 je
pense pas que la Grèce était la
meilleure équipe d'Europe bon ben
l'euro donc
ça peut arriver sur une compétition que
d'un coup bah ouais donc même en sport
collectif
la France c'était la meilleure équipe
enfin on joue 10 fois la Coupe du Monde
on gagne pas 10 fois mais on a une bonne
équipe
c'est beau ce que tu dis Fab
non mais je veux dire ok c'est comme tu
prends l'athlétisme ok tu fais un faux
départ c'est fini ou je sais pas quoi
[Musique]
mais ça peut arriver quoi
la Belgique était la meilleure équipe
mais elle aurait jamais gagné la Coupe
du Monde c'est vrai que les Belges
étaient forts j'étais très fort
OK
ah oui alors dire
en fait mais bon après
plusieurs coups quelque part logique
[Musique]
parce que là bon faut supporter aussi
cette dame au centre dans la vie mais
bon pour l'instant tu cliques
[Musique]
prise prise 2
pensez
en fait qui le met dans un
il a perdu son initiative quoi en fait
j'ai compris il a voulu en fait si tu
ressens qui disait c'était pas décalé
c'était de
se mettre derrière
alors
je sais pas quel point c'est simple ou
pas mais c'est hyper logique
tu gardes le dessin que touché tu veux
mettre ta tour en D1 mais en fait c'est
comme dirait la douille toi joueur de
scandinave
et ouais en fait
il peut croire qu'il a F5 demain
il faut prendre
ok ça reste chaud tu peux prendre 4 mais
genre là c'est
qui a complètement implosé et on pensait
qu'il allait perdre tout seul et
finalement un peu comme souvent dans ce
match quand on pense qu'il y en a un qui
est imposé et Claude va l'écraser c'est
l'autre qui contre un close quoi c'est
pas c'est un petit peu comme sur une
game de lol bon je suis pas gros joueur
de lol mais en gros
tu as une grosse avance en Gold et puis
dès que tu as une grosse avance en Gold
en fait tu as l'équipe adverse
enfin dans ton équipe qui troll et puis
contre troll face ça fait que troll en
fait
voilà
[Musique]
je sais pas trop ce qui va se passer ce
qui va avoir Dame des quatre ou pas mais
bon tu as quand même peur sur cette
colonne de F5
je peux te faire mal tu as peut-être des
tours prend le 4 qui sont une menace je
pense
je sais pas si tu fais un coup neutre
est-ce que tu reprends 4 ça fait mal ou
pas
par contre il est sur torrent qu'un coup
comme tour des 8 tabasse c'est aussi
l'idée
4 est si forts
c'est très concret enfin ça marche ça
marche pas je sais pas quoi dire en fait
c'est
non mais je veux dire qu'en fait dame ça
tient parce que ça tient il y a rien à
expliquer dans le 7 ça aurait pu être un
knock out un chaos mais là il se trouve
que dame descart qui est quand même le
coup le plus normal enfin tu te replaces
tu touches tout chez l'adversaire
mais il y a rien à expliquer en fait le
problème c'est que j'ai trois qui marche
c'est un peu étonnant c'était tellement
proche de prendre tous ces cinq mais il
se trouve c'est le cas donc bon
[Musique]
priorités partout avec les Blancs donc
en vrai même ça est-ce que c'est même ça
c'est questionnable en fait
bon donc
je te donne le bâton pour me faire
battre c'est même pas terminé enfin
c'est semi terminé mais tu sens que ça
tu vas pouvoir avoir mieux quand même
oui non mais bien sûr tu sens que le
truc où tu donnes la partie c'est déjà
pas fini fini donc
tu as pas les prix au madame des quatre
jouets la partie a tourné Mesdames et
Messieurs le cirque Pinder continue
voilà c'était moins part des risques
mais quand même un petit peu on peut se
faire un peu plaise quand même il y a eu
deux trois gaffes
ouais gafette enfin ouais
évidemment mais c'est pour ça que
c'était pas
mais c'est une logique bien sûr c'est
non mais pas facile mais bon c'est
champion du monde tu peux tu peux
l'avoir tu peux vraiment la fin là
c'est pas facile mais oui non mais
évidemment ça je suis pas du tout sûr
que je l'aurais eu du tout toi non plus
fin genre c'est pas comme le F3 ou bon
là c'est trop mais c'est quand même
enfin là on parle quand même une finale
du Championnat du Monde quoi dame 8 pour
avoir le foot qui peut venir en C5
c'est pas facile mais tu tapes un peu à
café non mais toi
j'ai intuitivement je préfère qu'elles
sont le 7 parce que je la sens mais
quand tu calcules les lignes tu peux te
rendre compte que oui en fait non en 8
c'est mieux mais ça bon
non mais du coup mais du coup ça peut
gagner pour une peau ça peut tout
tourner la route tourne un peu tourner
les amis ah c'est extraordinaire comme
parti on vit une partie de génie une
nouvelle fois les amis c'est terrible
parce qu'on peut jamais prévoir là ça
fait deux jours de suite
on n'a pas les coups quoi
alors possible d'ailleurs bizarrement
c'est le coup numéro 1 de l'ordi mais
franchement
humainement tu viens de faire dame
dis-lui ça donne un autre truc aussi
comme on dit dans le chat c'est que sur
Dame des quatre on pouvait aussi avoir
du F5 et du coup sur Fougères
c'est ce que je voulais essayer de créer
dans l'autre et surtout prends des cinq
échecs du coup on peut prendre de la
tour évidemment et attaque un peu tout
partout et ok non mais bien bien bravo
n'est pas Dame des quatre bien joué il a
eu le bon coup au bon moment
physiquement n'empêche on rigole on
rigole mais on l'a vu physiquement et
complètement différent il rôdait il
était là
dès qu'il a senti digne c'est tu te sens
un peu comme les comme les chiens comme
les chiens
égorité digne et il s'est complètement
remis tiens
c'était ma stratégie c'était bien U et
après tu es comme ça tout le long quoi
je crois pas enfin bon je peux plus
dîner les coups
[Musique]
je vais te faire j'en sais rien
mais bon
c'est trop le foutoir au milieu quoi
tu peux prendre ton français sur la
colonne et tu sens que ça peut
se passer en fait mais ça qui est
extraordinaire c'est pour ça que c'est
une belle partie
[Musique]
intensité
niveau on sait pas ce qui se passe
scénario quoi oui là on est sur du
hasard non c'est plein là
ouais mais c'est ça qui est beau dans
les échecs c'est que là n'importe quel
quick peuvent donner une pièce tout peut
arriver là ça donne l'impression d'une
seule battle qui dure avec des parties
pas en trois plus zéro comme on fait
d'habitude on se battle avec des parties
en 6 heures quoi et ça c'est beau
mais du coup je
dommage en plus il savait que c'était un
coup important il a vraiment pris le
temps il a calculé et mais juste ils ont
trouvé une idée de ce battle ce battle
fait une partie par semaine
et tu mets deux gars tu les fais jouer
pendant 6 heures que tu en mets des
cadences longues tu mets une caméra et
tu les films quoi et tu commandes sur la
partie à fond pendant 6 heures il faut
bien qu'il se lève quand même entre les
coups tu mets deux mecs moi 8500 la
seule bataille géante une game par
semaine il faut qu'il soit filmé quoi
ils font non un peu c'est ça peut être
extraordinaire l'idée de zinzin quoi
il y aurait tout en 5 minutes
malheureusement ouais mais faudrait
qu'il y ait de l'argent en jeu faut leur
mettre masse de pression sur celui qui
gagne il gagne 200 balles je suis prêt à
aller prendre du fric dans ta gueule
quoi mais genre la pression pour
qu'il soit au plus mal quoi et tu
regardes la game pendant 4 heures tu
regardes s'écrouler quoi
la game tu les suis avec une cam quoi
alors connard tu as perdu quoi tu
l'enfonces quoi il va pas être bien
[Musique]
ça va tricher mais non ça triche pas tu
mets plein d'arbitres enfin tu fais tout
pour qu'il soit au fond du trou quoi
non mais en gros évidemment mais là
c'est un peu ce que eux ils vivent hein
ils sont pas bien c'est pour ça aussi le
niveau 2 des fois ils font des coups
parce que c'est bah c'est dur en fait de
jouer hyper bien quand tu es sous grande
pression
là
grâce à leur game nepo hashtag n'est
pudding a été top traîne de Twitter
parce que tout le monde se foutait genre
que là c'était terrible non mais c'est
ouais
j'ai une petite ligne pour eux
H4 tu reprends G2 roi projet
il faut H7
ça peut être beau
découverte contre découverte
ce qui serait pas l'heure d'une petite
pub en fait ah ouais c'est vrai
c'est l'heure de la pub à ses amis c'est
l'heure de la petite puba on se retrouve
pour la suite
dans une petite dizaine une très petite
dizaine de minutes si ça joue on viendra
un peu plus tôt avec des coups
intéressants ne bougez surtout pas le
plus intéressant et à venir mesdames et
messieurs à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis il y a eu le F5 on a aussi
check un peu Twitter ce qui se disait à
Nantes comme nous un tour 5 il a pas du
tout compris bien évidemment
c'était un coup que lui aussi enfin il
dit qu'il aurait même pas considéré le
coup
tu l'as pas de calcul des trucs et que
tu dis ah ma toile sera utile ici
bon après de toute façon on peut
confirmer avec leur dit que c'était pas
ouf mais il va avoir oui une idée
profonde qui
[Musique]
il n'y a pas besoin quoi
peu importe donc là dans le direct il a
joué F5
le problème c'est qu'à te reprendre ça
attaque la dame ça s'attaque lequel
si je bouffe deux tu bouffe cette mais
bon tu es en train de faire un peu
n'importe quoi tu as donné la paire de
fou tu vas mettre une dame au fraise
c'est pas l'idée quoi non mais l'idée
c'est clairement mais dessus a priori il
faut donner la qualité ok feu ou tout
reprend je sais pas enfin dans un sens
ou l'autre
moi j'aurais plutôt
prends il prend on prend et quoi
mais ça c'est déjà pas dit qu'il le joue
non mais bon
sont bons et ça va dans tous les sens
ok
bonjour ok
F5
mais bon Ding prend le risque de perdre
enfin
la position elle est intéressante mais
comparativement à ce qu'il a eu
après ils disent qu'il y a du cavalier
bécadre aussi c'est le coup de l'ordi ok
au lieu
effectivement tu viens vers des trois tu
fourchettes tu fais des choses
bah écoute c'est un gros combat tout
d'un coup c'était juste que tu passes de
avantage noir tranquille
ça a l'air fort à vrai dire je vois pas
trop pourquoi
ou tu te fais juste un Pro 4 et basta ok
je vois pas en quoi il a amélioré sa fin
pardon
je vois pas pourquoi les Noirs seraient
mieux ici en fait non mais là non enfin
l'intérêt de tout le truc
quoi mais c'est pas optimal c'est pas
une faute il a bien fait fouger 3 et 3
donc c'est pas du tout ce qu'il a vu
il voulait ce qu'il fait la qualité mais
donc je savais pas dans quel sens quand
je t'avais dit on a regardé les feuilles
parce qu'on a regardé les feuilles
OK
enfin qui joue
[Musique]
qui joue quoi
il veut planter un caillou des 3 je
pense
que tu pourras pas l'empêcher
il veut planter en Détroit
et je sais pas trop bah c'est compliqué
pas trop bien joué la phase avec ce
Taure 5 pour en arriver là mais il y a
rien d'absurde non plus quoi
il y a une idée quoi il veut mettre son
cavalier en trois
F8
je sais pas ce qui se passe je sais pas
comment il juge la position les gars
donc ça veut peut-être dire qu'il a pas
jugé ça comme mieux pour moi
c'est en fait il a loupé avec son tour
et puis là bah il retombe sur ses pattes
il se dit bon bah finalement
et je sais pas ce qu'il a loupé pour le
coup
il a mal
[Musique]
le c'était normal non c'était normal
mais enfin ça veut dire que enfin
cette coup elle est pas absurde enfin
il y a une logique il y a une cohérence
dans des coups de lignes qui sont pas
optimaux et c'est la vie c'est dur les
meilleurs que tout le temps
mais en fait c'est vrai quand on voit la
position alors on m'aventure 5 une
dernière fois
ok mais là on a pas de doute les noirs
sont mieux
je sais pas comment je sais pas donc
comment je sais que
mesdames G5 c'est un coup qu'on a envie
de faire la main on y va en fait avec
Dame G5 après bon on a pas analyses en
détail je sais pas ce que l'ordi
commande il me défend c'est peut-être H4
mais que je suis content quand même de
me libérer les colonnes de
[Musique]
quoi qu'on est bien après je te dis pas
que je gagne enfin oui bon
mais je veux dire et je sais pas il a
rejeté ça il a dû croire que tu ressens
qu'il amélioré un truc je sais pas où
alors on est pas dans sa tête mais qui a
un truc qui doit échappé et que
maintenant bon il se retrouve là-dedans
non mais ça va aller c'est juste que
comparativement en fait ça m'a fait peur
mais ça va ah non mais
il le sait lui-même
mais bon ok
voilà s'il peut il va nous amener ce
qu'il en Détroit
et il sera magnifique il te prend les
colonnes pour les tours ou quoi donc
j'aime bien ta variante en fait
parce que les blancs peuvent être malin
si le cavalier tu le train téléporte en
D3 enfin tu veux juste avec la souris
pour que soit visuel
il est chiant il te prend les colonnes
pour les tours il aide à avancer les
pions il attaque B2
ça peut être très bien
les fêtes et comment par rapport je sais
pas similaire je pense
c'est une histoire de choix là
je peux pas te dire que c'était mieux
que c'était moins bien mais je pense
même tourner un ça va j'ai pas trop me
casser la tête
à un moment c'est pour ça que je m'avais
fait non mais oui du coup peut-être tu
dois attendre enfin non mais là du coup
n'est pas à des coups alors attention un
tout peu encore arrivé dans cette partie
ne partez pas tout de suite parce que vu
le scénario du match il peut s'en passer
encore beaucoup Fab une époque
je me sentir un rassuré en disant je
suis quand même passé près du précipice
mais là
ça se trouve une partie normale mais là
je donne 60% de nuls pas plus
les deux peuvent gagner en fait
en tout cas bravo Yann quand même qui a
réussi à resserrer les boulons il a pas
il a pas il a pas dévissé
et
[Musique]
je sais pas quelle couleur j'aimerais
mieux jouer cette opposition peut-être
les blancs quand même
après je joue mieux quand j'ai une
qualité de moi donc peut-être que
j'aurais plus intérêt à prendre les
Noirs
les Blancs si tu juges mais que tu te
dirais je la jouerai mieux et en
pratique je prends je suis désolé de me
répéter mais non exactement la même
chose que nous il dit quoi là bah il dit
que Ding a fait un sacrifice de qualité
professionnelle que ça doit être
peut-être des compensations suffisantes
pour les Noirs mais ce qu'il est mieux
non et il comprend pas pourquoi est-ce
qu'il a joué comme ça enfin non mais oui
enfin nous on nous prend pour des
abrutis quand on le dit mais genre à
Nantes bon là
il dit mot pour mot ce que j'ai dit
ok c'est pas mal mais
ce qu'on respecte à non de peut-être tu
comprends tu regardes que avec l'ordi tu
es nul ça 53 ans tu es que 9e mondiale
retourne dans ton EHPAD
évidemment à Nantes c'est
un immense joueur une légende un des
plus grands de l'histoire
incroyable joueur
Vichy qui jouait très vite et qui
mettait une énorme pression bien
mais
monsieur
il prend pas les gens pour des idiots et
il parle bien ouais il va pas clash mais
ils disent qu'il doit dire non mais il
va pas te vendre un Nakamura carlsan sur
Internet comme le match du siècle quoi
non non il est normal il est normal il
te prend pas pour un idiot à Nantes
j'apprécie
du terme ils disent qu'il pense quoi il
est pas ah il le dit avec des il est
poliss un petit peu quoi mais garde le
fond de ce qu'il pense il invente pas
n'importe quoi
parle bien
Mathieu serait même cramique dans un
table récente elle dit que
il est encore en top 10 mondial en fait
non c'est incroyable c'est vrai il y a
quelqu'un qui faisait remarquer qu'il y
a aucun jeune indien qui est encore
rattrapé quoi
il est incroyable ici
non il joue plus trop mais là la
dernière fois
de sa vie mais il a quand même fait un
bon tournoi il a même gagné des points
[Musique]
il serait pas il va pas le faire mais il
serait pas favori pour se qualifier au
candidats
53 piges non mais en fait il joue
toujours bien aux échecs lents et puis
en rapide il est bon enfin bah oui il
est fort enfin
là on dit des évidences mais je veux
dire évidemment enfin il est vieux pour
les échecs quoi
parce que m'a dit 5 bah je suis content
si je perdais 5 contre un ande bah non
ça va je signe tout de suite
la dernière fois
non mais c'est quand même hallucinant
mais tu vois si revient un championnat
du monde de Blitz ou de Rapid il serait
capable il serait pas du tout favori
mais il ferait partie des outsiders
capables de gagner c'est incroyable non
non mais oui enfin je veux dire ouais
c'est vraiment vieux 53 ans pour les
échecs on dirait pas parce que les
échecs c'est un
c'est pas quand même comme le tennis où
tu es bon oui mais 50 ans tu joues plus
mais en fait ouais au delà de 40 ans
c'est déjà pas facile parce que ça
retraite à 25 avec 42 ans crème Nica
peut préparer
ouais ça devient dur et donc un ordre
qui c'est pas 42 c'est 53 11 ans d'écart
10 maintient alors voilà c'est
c'est vraiment quelque chose
alors j'ai peut-être une question pour
toi qui est en train de me venir à
l'esprit Fab est-ce que tu
recommanderais ton nouveau cahier
d'entraînement pour pour Vichy pour pour
entretenir sa tactique alors pour Vichy
non
mais pour pour la plupart des gens
présents ici oui
est-ce que tu peux un petit peu nous en
parler Fab ouais on a déjà parlé un peu
mais oui alors petit cahier
d'entraînement 80 pages
sympathique à lire
dans le sens où il y aura des petits
quiz culture générale les petits jeux à
faire 286 exercices de tactique
donc c'est exercice sa vision tactique
ou quoi et de bien les faire parce que
souvent je connais trop de joueurs qui
font les exercices sur internet donc ça
c'est bien ça je recommande mais qui en
fait vont cliquer le coup tempo et pas
prendre le temps d'essayer de trouver
les défenses ou quoi là tu es sur un
cahier un livre tu es obligé tu peux pas
bouger les pièces quoi donc tu dois
calculer donc ça va peut-être vous aider
à prendre les bons réflexes et puis donc
voilà sympathique à lire en couleur 80
pages pas cher moins de 10 euros 9,90 je
mets le lien dans les voilà alors je
voyais en vente tiède pour quel niveau
j'ai l'impression que feed jusqu'à
1700 ça va mais tu peux même le lire
plus loin parce que il a un côté
sympathique à lire mais que je pense
qu'à 16007
il y a pas de souci pour le faire
moins bien sûr et voilà et puis niveau
de chez scum on va dire jusqu'à
peut-être
[Musique]
donc livre voilà dispo après comment en
précommande pardon qui sera en vente
dans les librairies et les magasins tout
ça à partir du 25 mai et vous me
donnerez des retours
on peut améliorer ou quoi 90 en couleur
avec plus de 250 exercices et bien
évidemment aussi des mots mêlés quatre
mots mais les femmes peut-être trois
mots
sympathique à faire quoi
et des exercices d'échec quand même à
foison en plus de 250
voilà cahier de vacances mais qui peut
être aussi pris comme un quai pas de
vacances d'entraînement d'entraînement
mais
il a un petit côté tu vois comme je
voyais comme un les livrets de vacances
pour les enfants quand tu passes donner
sur l'autre que tu fais le petit
programme de révision et d'un peu
d'année d'après et tu as des exercices
et voilà un peu dans ce sens là en mode
en mode tranquille
parfait pour aller aux chiottes c'est
vrai que c'est un bon livre sur mon live
c'est un bon livre de shot non mais
vraiment
aux toilettes machin tu peux te faire
deux trois satellites d'être toujours
collé sur le téléphone
hop tu peux l'amener à la plage tu peux
l'amener dans les transports en commun
tu peux au café enfin où tu veux ou sur
une planche chez toi
[Musique]
voilà
je ne pourrai pas lâcher alors tu
devrais quitter le live Noval aussi
parce que je touche appartient à Amazon
donc je pense que tu devrais quitter le
live histoire d'être
cohérent avec toi même
et au cas où oui si vous n'avez pas il
sera dispo à la FNAC ailleurs
mais
va sur Youtube ça appartient alphabet
qui est un peu l'équivalent d'Amazon
donc je conseille pas d'aller sur
Youtube non plus frérot je pense qu'il
faut que oui en fait portant
twitch on n'a pas le choix
tu peux ne pas regarder
moi j'ai pas le choix vas-y tu as le
choix de regarder pas enfin
dans trigger comme disent les Anglais
il y a qui si tu veux bah tu peux aller
regarder sur kick c'est une autre
plateforme c'est notre plateforme ça
c'est casino et un peu le monde des
films plus de 18 ok
Amazon
quand même
et
plus pendant ce temps on s'est pris un
petit tour
c'était le coup de Kev le coup de Kev
qui donc veut anticiper le cavalier B4
pour aller
aussi sur les serveurs Amazon
mais du coup raison de plus pour lire le
livre le jour il sort tranquillou et
voilà
ok après je sais pas si il pouvait plus
ou moins l'éviter jouer de la
préfectureen
qui change la dernière tournante
échecs comme ça sur iPhone j'ai torréfi
donc je te pousse dans le coin
ok je commence à être un peu mieux blanc
je vais pouvoir la pousser ben
selon enfin selon
plutôt incroyable
pouvoir espérer
non mais c'est un très très haut niveau
de j'ai jamais vu j'ai mal champion du
monde ça joue aussi fort Fab attention
ne glisse pas mais là c'est hallucinant
en fait c'est
ça se voit en fait ça peut pas aller et
même très bien joué par de la part de
nepo après froid par contre il s'est
bien saisi mais il a pas non plus il a
fait des coups forcément mais il les a
fait il les a fait le tour
parce que tu vois il y avait tout droit
qui était possible il a fait bien jouer
il a bien joué la phase mais non selon
ouf c'est quoi la règle bah tu peux
l'expliquer vas-y alors la règle de ouf
si vous avez deux pièces pareil donc là
vous avez deux tours et que l'adversaire
n'en a qu'une c'est dans votre intérêt
d'en échanger une pour supprimer
le la sorte de pièces chez l'adversaire
parce qu'il considère que vos deux
tourbes elles peuvent faire la même
chose dans la position donc si vous en
avez enfin une va suffire à faire la
chose et l'adversaire à une tour pour
faire un truc donc si vous lui enlever
la tour il
pourra plus faire ce que faisait une
tour quoi il aura plus cette aptitude
dans la position et donc c'est une bonne
règle c'est pas vrai pour les fous ouais
mais parce qu'ils sont différents il y
en a un qui blanche et l'autre sur case
noire donc il considère évidemment les
deux fous comme deux pièces différentes
et logique mais en fait pareil donc
c'était à deux cavaliers que ça en a
qu'un tu échanges ton cavalier
et pour les tours voilà
c'est marrant parce que c'est la
première ligne de l'ordi et cette règle
elle se vérifie mais tellement elle est
incroyable en fait c'est ça marche hyper
souvent Anderson aide je ne porte que
j'ai trouvé dans le livre d'ailleurs de
d'Axel Smith celui qui a écrit le truc
qui a un autre truc
relativement mauvais j'ai enfin moi je
l'ai pas aimé simplement il y a ce
chapitre de génie et donc le livre vaut
le coup juste pour juste pour un
chapitre donc j'ai acheté le livre 25
balles je pense mais tu es contente
parce que ce truc que j'ai appris bah en
plus j'ai plus la prendre à d'autres
personnes mais ce truc en fait il aurait
coûté 250 euros j'aurais dit oui enfin
prendre mon argent quoi pète-moi le cul
quoi non mais
c'est quoi le livre c'était pump up your
rating chess ou je sais pas pub quelque
chose de Excel Smith et et ce truc là je
ne le savais pas non en fait vous pouvez
l'avoir intuitivement mais moi de poser
les mots dessus tu le sais bien c'est
bien
c'est important de poser les mots sur
sur les concepts pour les avoir plus
vite et donc la tour des 7 tours C7
c'est hyper logique il y a le sait
évidemment lui aussi et donc tu l'as
très naturellement ce tour des 7 jours
c'est 7 et c'est très très bien joué
et ouais bonne époque qui va plus courir
en salle de repos qui est là qui va la
gagner il va juste la gagner en fait
incroyable ce match incroyable génial
extraordinaire scénario
c'est un mec qui a fait j'aime en étant
adulte ouais mais il était fort il était
pas mauvais jeunes déjà attention
oui c'est battu mais il était déjà
maître
je connais un petit peu personnellement
on a joué dans le même club à
Montpellier mais
[Musique]
des années 2010 quoi mais il était déjà
24,80 ou je sais pas quoi enfin
échecs donc ça pousse plutôt le roi dans
le coin j'imagine t'as pas envie de te
prendre des torréfutes et chaque vidéo
RH3 même si H1 est possible aussi non
non mais je veux plus logique parce que
le jour où j'ai trop hâte voilà tu peux
sortir de là donc
du coup dans le fameux chapitre il parle
de la règle mais du coup j'imagine
ça fait trois pages mais en fait le truc
c'est que c'est tellement important
comme concept que tu es content de
l'avoir après tu le vérifies par
toi-même mais j'y aurais pas pensé par
moi-même à ce truc là
sans savoir ce que tu veux faire du coup
une fois que tu le sais ben tu vas pas
me tourner
chaque ok on s'attend à rouage de la
part d'un épaule et après il faudra
sauver cette attaquer
et d'où l'importance de lire quand même
des livres de temps en temps de faire
des cahiers d'entraînement des exercices
que tu vois des trucs que tu vas que tu
peux utiliser en partie
tu vois tu as ton brûlant qui dit
Kévin j'ai récemment acheté ton livre
gagner aux échecs même quand on débute
et je tiens à dire qu'il est superbe
écoute merci à toi et donc là ouais
entraînement c'est un peu la suite en
quelque sorte exercices
parce que parce que je dois dire c'est
que souvent je vois la question de gens
qui ont du mal à trouver des plans
savent plus trop qu'à faire dans les
positions qui ont bien pris les
principes de base il se débrouille ça
fait aux ovaires il donne pas de pièces
tu vois mais ils ont pas trop d'idées et
là en fait le livre bleu donc progresser
aux échecs c'est une compilation de il y
a quoi 25 parties
qui sont commentés et qui te montre un
peu comment une partie peut être jouée
les plans possibles quelque chose
quelque partit un peu remarquable qui en
intérêt pour apprendre justement des
plans de mettre en oeuvre des choses
donc c'est pas mal mais oui dans un
second temps c'est pas le même public
mais c'est quelqu'un qui commence avec
le livre rouge qui progressent il peut
après dans un second temps être
intéressé
par le progresser aux échecs
s'adresse à kalelo alors au début c'est
pour débutant c'est pour débutant
jusqu'à 1200 1300 hello ça progresse
petit à petit et après tu as le tu as le
progresser aux échecs donc le bleu qui
va de 1300 jusqu'à bah moi j'ai des amis
2300 fits qui l'ont lu il se décontant
que j'en ai acheté un pour le club parce
que vraiment bien ils sont très heureux
de l'avoir parce que tu as 25 parties
connues quand même donc c'est c'est
parti qui sont bien à connaître à tous
niveaux que tu sois 1500 élo ou grands
mètres tu peux le dire avec plaisir
c'est bien écrit en plus Samir Robin a
une super plume et
et le cahier d'entraînement bah c'est un
peu entre les enfin entre les deux entre
guillemets ah c'est un complément des
deux ça peut être en complément des deux
on faisait 6 jouer donc on s'attend à
tort c'est ça
qui est hyper logique toute façon
maintenant que tu es là tu te fais
attaquer la tour tu vas avoir du
qui rones mais tu as pas envie sans plus
sous pour A4
donc tu as vraiment pas envie qu'il a
tort c'est vite quoi
c'est sûr qu'il va faire ça
évidemment
bon c'est peut-être pas gagnant encore
mais là maintenant c'est c'est juste du
jeu à deux résultats oui tu es obligé de
prendre
faut prendre et
[Musique]
c'est pas grave pour les non
obligé de prendre ben ouais parce que si
tu décales la tour tu perds C4 alors là
tu as tout qui attaqué
[Musique]
le fousser 5 si tu veux cinq tu sais
bouffer soit le cavalier soit le fousser
6 et tu auras une pièce de moins dans
deux coups donc tu peux pas
en fait il y en a il y aura il y a 10000
manières de gagner une pièce
[Musique]
c'est incroyable
tu penses qu'il va la gagner mais Ding
[Musique]
parce qu'il a pas le choix faut prendre
et c'est à Digne de défendre maintenant
et à espérer qu'il y a ne va pas jouer
des meilleurs coups
c'est il faisait le mec un peu Ding en
conférence hier il a un peu trop fait le
mec ouais mais Rita du coup
non mais après les conférences faut pas
prendre ça premier degré c'est comment
vous dire
il répond ils sont courtois j'aimerais
bien dire dégoûté il est quand même
aller en conférence il a quand même
répondu il a pas envoyé chez les gens
donc ils font le taf pro bien Magnus
sera envoyé chez les gens il a déjà fait
mais
après ça peut être des infos fiables à
100% en fait tu vas pas te livrer donner
tes doutes tes certitudes tu es mal
enfin
c'est quand même un jeu enfin tu vas pas
lui donner toutes les infos à l'équipe
adverse
bon alors faut prendre ces 7
donc maintenant deux choix est-ce qu'on
s'accroche à ses cadres il faut des 5 ou
est-ce qu'on élimine en prenant la carte
bon spontanément j'aurais pu se prendre
un 4 mais
si je peux pas récupérer une pièce c'est
ça
obligé du coup voilà il y a même pas de
choix du coup
c'est 6 et on se remet un peu d'aplomb
ok ça marche mais
ok ça va ça tient encore la partie
timorée quoi
te
[Musique]
tapis aujourd'hui
on a un Fab affûté
34 minutes contre 43 on aura pas de
problème de temps il reste que 8 coups
la pendule n'aura pas de d'impact
aujourd'hui
bah normalement
pour l'instant c'est pas une finale très
longue
finalement qui peut durer longtemps
mais là je pense pas qu'il y aura de
grosses erreurs maintenant en fait
non mais une petite erreur peut suffire
à glisser pour les pour les Noirs en
fait
maintenant donc il est tranquille mais
par contre une petite erreur peut
suffire à faire glisser des
c'est incroyable ce qu'il a fait digne
quand même dans cette partie
bah il a raté
[Musique]
en fait il
n'a pas de chance quelque part c'est
qu'en fait Yann a vraiment fait quelque
chose d'affreux dans l'ouverture c'est
infecte quoi
Eding en fait il a rien fait d'aussi mal
mais
en fait l'accumulation de choses pas
terrible même s'il y avait du sens ça
l'a amené là quoi et
ça a inventé une vie avec ton ressent
quoi
c'est quand même assez horrible comme
coup si t'as pas de suite concrète qui
marche sur le 5 c'est horrible
F3 en fait oui
moi je peux pas dire toi cinq et bien
joué c'est le temps de la partie mais
[Musique]
mais en fait oui après le problème c'est
que le problème des coups de pions c'est
comme on peut pas reculer les pions
quand tu as vraiment fait ta connerie et
tu as mal enfin tu ressens et au pire tu
repars en 8 on t'a fait n'importe quoi
mais c'est toujours moins grave quoi
mais là il s'est enféré dans une
n'importe quoi de chez n'importe quoi il
sait vraiment on ferait dans une
appartement quoi en fait elle a voulu
justifier et après il y a peu de choses
ça pue mais bon c'est les échecs hein
c'est ça joue ça marche ça marche pas au
coup le coup
ablement de faire une vraie pause
de 2 minutes tout à l'heure voilà on se
met une jolie pub et puis on revient
dans une petite dizaine de minutes
on est resté plus longtemps sur le
moment important ok bah on va revenir à
tout de suite les amis à toute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs on est de retour
il s'est passé les coups les plus
logiques qu'on avait plus ou moins
anticipé donc l'échange des tours fout
des 5 avaler ces trois qu'on avait vu
qu'il y a eu des trois intermédiaire
tour ces deux fous c'est 6 à 5
ouais bon c'est logique il y aura
peut-être pu y avoir d'autres coups de
partir ailleurs mais dans l'autre ça
c'est logique et
[Musique]
ça va en fait pour un peu de bol ouais
je pense que ça va faire nul
toi tranquillement en fait bah après tu
vois s'il y a Niri ce que je sais pas et
peut-être que c'est trop n'était pas ouf
très logique mais peut-être
commencer par A5
tu peux avoir ou pas c'est pas de
l'équivalent de l'ouverture qui
c'est une critique vite fait enfin c'est
juste c'est probablement pas le meilleur
mais peu importe
[Musique]
parce que c'est pas facile de bouger les
Noirs quand même on leur père de fouille
contre le bruit de case le pion prêt à
marcher vers l'avant le roi quand même
qui s'active vers le centre assez
rapidement donc
donc il y a des belles compensations
[Musique]
donc tu as échangé le cavalier donc ce
sont des trois il était très gênant
dans là il est plus là alors pourquoi
pas mais je vois pas pourquoi les blancs
pourraient enfin évidemment tu as l'air
symboliquement mieux mais je vois pas de
plan pour gagner
d'ailleurs je crois que sur B3 il y a
pion 30 tours et B2
[Musique]
oui bon ok c'est nul nul sera content
après qu'elle faut nous parle de roi G3
c'est un cours je vais travailler
le jeu en fait avec le roi est vraiment
beau c'est pour ça que c'est pas bête
d'essayer de les changer c'est
probablement un bon plan pour les blancs
d'ailleurs
mais a priori il part vraiment suffisant
on sait que ça va trop ouais mais bon
enfin vu qu'on est pas au bout de nos
surprises
c'est ton jamais
et
[Musique]
pas du tout au bout de notre surprise
Fab
en tout cas qu'elle partir encore
aujourd'hui finalement
animé
c'est le mot
animé rebondissements
et on aura 14 parties dans ce match à
coup sûr et peut-être des départages
dimanche matin ça va être beau hein
quatre parties en 25 + 10 mais Nico je
sais pas dans quel état
là aujourd'hui normalement ça va il est
le plus dur est passé mais
[Musique]
je sais pas si du coup il reprend ses
esprits il recommence la prochaine te
refaire des dinguerie pareil
il est peut-être un peu déçu de pas
pouvoir jouer le gain en réalité
c'est pas si mal mais là pendant la
partie de toute façon tu t'en fiches de
ce qui s'est passé avant il faut que tu
juges au moment T et donc quand il fait
tourner cette torse et 7 il se dit bon
bah il y en a plus qu'un qui joue pour
le bien c'est moi il sait pas à quel
point bon maintenant il regarde et
peut-être pas en fait
dommage mais bon
qui favorit en départage là c'est très
difficile de donner un favori parce que
comme tu peux le constater
ça se joue pas au niveau de jeu
intrinsèque les joueurs sont loin de
leur niveau et ça joue plus sur les
nerfs donc qui aura les nerfs les plus
solides ça c'est difficile à
prévoir parce que quand on pense qu'il
Yann va complètement chuter bah il se
ressaisit quand on pense que que
en gros on imagine jamais ce qui va se
passer quoi
exactement donc
[Musique]
difficile de donner un favori là c'est
tu jettes une pièce quand tu regardes
donc il va jamais madame bah il aimerait
bien il est moins bien il est là pour ça
mais une fois que tu avances en E3
comment tu passes l'étape d'après
ça la difficulté quoi les quatre parties
de départage sont le même jour elles
s'enchaînent d'ailleurs
et le jour où tu en E3 bah peut-être que
les blancs ils vont essayer de
t'attaquer mais de fou etc ou pas
il voulait peut-être plus que ça
aussi c'est bon c'est pas trop mais de
toute façon a priori c'est une bonne
tentative dans l'escalier des trois qui
prend trop de cases quoi qui est chiant
mais bon ça a pas l'air de lui suffire
en tout cas lui il voulait mieux mais
c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu penser avoir
plus que ça encore
oui je vais changer le fou
disons
qui fait un très bon duo avec son son
compère juste à côté qui contrôle
beaucoup de cases
[Musique]
la première question qu'on se pose
cavalier C1
tu auras un qui est 3 tours 2 qui est
dans ces deux je reviens des trois après
est-ce que tu veux venir en D2 et me
faire jeter les trois au moins tu as
gagné tant des deux par rapport à ton C2
alors je sais pas ce que tu as gagné
mais tu peux dire ça ou alors ce que
c'est une répétition de nulle tacite une
profession nul tacite je veux dire mais
c'est
pas l'air mal
il leur dit lui dire moi aussi
ok tu veux B2
en force tu as activé le roi ah ok bravo
si on te dit c'est le coup je vais
comprendre tu vas comprendre tu vas
faire quel point 4.4 prise 4 3 5 et tu
vas voir qui est en B2
enfin tu vois tu vas le gagner
mais moi j'aurais pas envisagé le coup
en fait
c'est le premier coup non mais là
aussi tu fais marcher la ligne c'est
hyper facile mais si on est sur même pas
le coup
est-ce que je peux même du coup avoir
envie de faire des deux de trois ou
c'est trop
tu vois pour essayer de faire un bon
j'aurais pas fait par principe parce que
je pense pas que je joue le gain du tout
et que je me mets dans la merde mais
bon faut quand même regarder avec les
Blancs tu peux pas laisser se faire ça
sans être sûr parce que bon tu retouches
à 5 enfin si tu gagnes à 5 commence à
faire beaucoup et tu as le droit ou pas
du tout
parce que si j'arrive finalement
j'ai envie de te dire tu mets un échec
mais ça ne sert à quoi à rien tu active
qui a eu des trois tours de
et puis voilà OK
ça peut en terminer comme ça parce que
je vois pas de bruit
j'en sais rien moi-même c'est pas le
style de la maison je pense pas mais
écoute
en fait ça ça est-ce qu'on voyait sur
son langage corporel genre un peu de
déception et ça irait dans le sens de
prendre nul
enfin de prendre une que il trouve rien
et donc il fait des coups un peu comme
ça à côté
bon là actuellement il peut juste
répéter une fois et retrouver la
position qu'il avait donc ça hypothèque
pas du tout le cavalier de Cavalière 4
mais ça traduit ce qu'on voit à l'image
mais ouais ici c'était pas possible
c'est car il est simple normal
donc il n'en reste plus que 4 avant le
contrôle du temps
donc ils sont ils sont à l'aise au
niveau
et tout reprend le 4 on nous propose le
truc c'est fou prank cavalier prend et
regarde en fait les pions ils sont sur
case noir des pions ils sont sur casse
blanche
de casse noir aussi donc il tape tes
pions et en plus le roi est plus avancé
j'ai beaucoup de choses
après c'était pas foutu parce que vu que
sur fout des quatre tu as peut-être
qu'il y a des six qui est français 4
mais bon le roi ils font ce
avec les Blancs là il y en a un qui perd
c'est toi quoi tu as une caisse de
manger ouais donc
en plus
aller dans le dans le truc dont on
parlait Maxime le cavalier F4 pour un
peu jouer quand même
mais bon
cavaliers C1
peut-être
ouais
c'est sûr
est-ce que tu peux mettre une petite pub
peut-être parce qu'il faut quand même
qu'on fait une pub de 15 secondes on est
là mais faut qu'on respecte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis bien timer par le Fab
c'est bon on a mis notre côté non une à
la fin et basta
c'est beau très à cheval sur les pubs
ouais mais bon on fait pas la pause on
fait juste la petite pub pour pour être
tranquille
parce que ça peut ça peut terminer
rapidement
ici si le jour a pas ouais enfin je
pense pas que c'est un intérêt
ça serait méga étonnant parce que je
crois pas que tu augmentes tes chances
de gains particulièrement enfin tu les
augmentes la situation de match si tu le
vois je pense c'est pas bête de le faire
parce que ça se voit qu'il y a il en a
marre et qui veut partir je pense tu
vois que tu mets un Carlson avec les
Noirs
à mon avis moi aussi c'est extrêmement
bien joué dans la situation de match
pour tout un tas de raisons mais ça me
paraît très difficile après si le trouve
franchement je mettrai un voire même
deux points d'exclamation à l'analyse
pour réussir même si ça donne pas le
gain et que
et que ça donne rien je mettrai je
mettrai les points d'exclamation dessus
il peut avoir envie réussisse donc on
disait qu'elle prend le 4 donc il y a
peut-être pas obligé mais bon c'est
normal
ok il prend fou prends tour prends un
dessin
quand j'ai quatre peut-être qui prend B2
pièces qui jouent quoi donc ça tu peux
pas vraiment
B2 c'est 3 qui est BK
et tu con tu consoles ton aile ton aile
roi et tu joues à l'aile dame ouais ça
je sors avec
pas prendre 4 en fait
au vu de ce qu'on voit qu'en fait là ça
nous fait suer 6 du coup ce fond on a
compris qu'il était fort fout des 6 tu
peux te mettre sur cette diagonale roi
F5
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
là si je passe mon tour avec les blancs
de regarder G4 F4 x 3 ouais 3 non ça
j'ai pas envie de le voir
je fais rien
en fait
mais je pense que c'est pas bête je peux
dire que dans le match le fait de jouer
ça tu rajoutes une pression quand même
[Musique]
mais c'était très très difficile heureux
on efface cette partie on veut plus voir
ça depuis bien longtemps et qui a été
trois
[Musique]
deux et ça va faire trois fois ouais bon
monsieur
la dernière on va revoir un truc comme
ça je crois parce qu'ils ont ils sont
ils en peuvent plus
et peut-être des départages ou pas
franchement
dur bon niveau s'en sortir
très bien mais Ding qui aurait pu
vraiment regretter la partie se dire ah
bah ouais moi aussi je suis pas passé si
loin finalement donc les deux peuvent
être contents oui les deux peuvent être
contents du résultat ce sont tous les
deux mécontents de leur partie mais
content du résultat voilà on va dire
comme ça donc demain je viens de repos
et on pourra souffler avant la dernière
ronde qui sera samedi et puis en cas de
nul samedi on aura des départages
dimanche mais samedi on va sûrement
avoir une partie
bouillante
ça va être très très beau mesdames et
messieurs donc on se retrouve samedi
à 11h pour la suite du championnat du
monde évidemment si vous voulez voir les
résumés des parties vous pouvez taper
Blitz stream sur Youtube et vous aurez
les résumés de toutes les parties mais
nous on va on va se quitter je vais
peut-être faire un raid sur chasse pour
parce que j'ai vu qu'il passait les
les conférences de presse maintenant
donc on va faire le petit raid et on se
retrouve et on se retrouve donc samedi
pour la suite du tournoi merci à tous
ciao ciao bye bye
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]